सो आई थिंक वी आर लाइव
गाइस ओ हेलो हेलो एवरी बडी लेट मी चेक
वंस एक बार मैं खुद भी चेक कर लेता हूं
गाइस जस्ट
वेट हां जी हां
जी हेलो हेलो हेलो गुड इवनिंग भाई सबको
गुड इवनिंग सभी लोग आ जाओ जल्दी से आ जाओ
फटाफट आ जाओ जल्दी से आ जाओ सभी सभी जवाइन
कर लो तब स्टार्ट करेंगे बहुत मजा आएगा लव
यू डि फोनिक्स लव यू
टू ओके काफी लोग पहले से आ जाते हैं हां
इंतजार में रहते हैं वो लोग आवाज आवाज सही
आ रही है आप लोगों को ऑडियो वीडियो सब
एकदम मस्त शानदार धमाकेदार है
ना हम चलिए बढ़िया बहुत बढ़िया तो आने
देते सबको जल्दी से फिर स्टार्ट करते हैं
100 प्लस आ जाओ यार जल्दी से फटाफट आ जाओ
जल्दी आ
जाओ चलो लाइक ठोकते आना जैसे जैसे आते जाओ
लाइक ठोकते जाओ तो चलिए यहां पर कौन-कौन
है हेलो द वाटसन
टा टाटा टोप ठीक है स्टेलर
तान्या
गौरव प्रांजुल
r78 वॉइस नॉट क्लियर क्या बात बोल रहे
हो वॉइस सही है ना भाई एक बोल रहा है वॉइस
नॉट क्लियर ऐसे कैसे यार मजाक कर रहे हो
क्या मस्त मस्त क्लियर वॉइस आ रही है भाई
बिल्कुल
हा जी गुड इवनिंग भाई लोग सभी
को गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग आई एम गुड आप
बताइए आप बताइए आ जाने देते हैं सबको आ
जाओ यार जल्दी आ जाओ फटाफट आ जाओ ऐसे कैसे
चलेगा नहीं आओगे तो 100 100
100 सर आई हैव प्रॉब्लम इन काली लिनिक्स
मशीन डेनिक्स बग हंटर वाले जो ग्रुप है
उसमें प्रॉब्लम्स पूछ लिया करो ना
यार आप यहां से पूछते हो तो यहां मैं आपकी
ज्यादा प्रॉब्लम्स को डील नहीं कर पाता
हूं मजबूरी है क्योंकि बहुत ज्यादा
टाइमिंग इशू टाइमिंग बहुत एक्सटेंड हो
जाता है
फिर हा स्टार्ट करेंगे बट सबसे पहले यह
बता दो गाइस आप सब लोगों ने एसक्यूएल आई
लैब्स मास्टर जो था जो मैंने आपको इंस्टॉल
करने का तरीका बताया था नक्स में भी बोला
था आप डायरेक्टली इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं एंड
आप विंडोज में भी कर सकते हैं जम का यूज
करके आप सबका वो इंस्टॉल हो चुका था
इंस्टॉल सबका हो चुका है पहले बता दीजिए
जल्दी से बताइए सबका इंस्टॉल हो चुका
है क्या बात है प्रहलाद वेरी गुड वेरी गुड
सबका हो गया ओके राहुल का हो गया तानिया
क्यों नहीं हुआ यार
कर लो ना उसको इजी है बहुत तो सेटअप हो
गया अर्थ वेरी
गुड सब बॉब सूट की ब्राउजर बहुत स्लो काम
कर रही है कुछ नहीं आपके सिस्टम की
प्रॉब्लम है बारबार एक मैसेज को मत करो
प्लीज स्पैम लगता है ठीक है ओके सुभोजित
लैपटॉप में इशू हो गया ठीक है कोई बात
नहीं उसको सही करा लीजिए लैपटॉप का इशू जो
है आपका ओके
गाइस तो आएंगे और लोग या क्या करें
स्टार्ट करें आप बताइए मैं तो यार 100
प्लस का वेट कर रहा हूं साइबर क्राइम कब
आएगा आएगा भाई जल्दी आएगा इन्वेस्टिगेटर
भाई टेंशन नहीं लेना है आपको साइबर क्राइम
ही है नेक्स्ट ट्रेनिंग हमारा जो आने वाला
है नेक्स्ट ट्रेनिंग जो है आपकी जो आने
वाली है वह साइबर क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेशन की
ही आने वाली है तो आपको ज्यादा टेंशन नहीं
लेना है बहुत जल्द अनाउंसमेंट आएगी उसकी
ठीक है डीले मेरे साइड से थोड़ा सा हो रहा
है बट बहुत जल्द आ
जाएगी साइबर क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेशन आएगी
डीडीएफएस 2.2 और एक इंटर्नशिप हम लच करें
वो भी आएगी सब चीज आएगी ठीक है
ओके साइबर क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेशन के जो
आपके ट्रेनर होने वाले हैं उनकी भी काफी
क्वेरीज आ रही है आती है मतलब कि कब कराओ
सर कब मैं ही थोड़ा डिले कर रहा हूं उसके
कुछ रीजन है और कुछ बात नहीं है बट जल्दी
मैं अनाउंस करूंगा ठीक है उसका आपको टेंशन
नहीं लेना है क्योंकि सारे मॉड्यूस फाइनल
हो चुके हैं सारी चीजें जो मे ट्रेनर से
कन्वर्सेशन हुई है सब कुछ फाइनल हो चुका
हमारा एंड नाउ वी आर गुड टू
लंच कैसे सॉल्व करूं स्पेक्स सही करो भाई
एपीएस हैकर पीसी की स्पेक्स सही होगी तो
सही
रहेगा ठीक
है बताएंगे भाई ट्रेनर के बारे में भी
आपको बताएंगे टेंशन नहीं लेना है टेंशन आप
मत लो ठीक है आपको पता है ना
इन्वेस्टिगेटर भाई मेरे ऊपर किसी भी तरह
की सोशल इंजीनियरिंग काम नहीं कर
ना आप कर सकते हो आप समझ रहे होग मैं क्या
बोल रहा हूं तो मैं ट्रेनर के बारे में
बताऊंगा टेंशन आपको नहीं लेना है ठीक है
बताया जाएगा ट्रेनर के बारे में आपके बारे
में सब बताया जाएगा ठीक
है
चलिए
ओके सर आईम न्यू इन योर चैनल वेलकम ब्रदर
वेलकम वेरी मच वेलकम वेलकम
गाइस आप लोगों का जवाब नहीं आता है बहुत
कम लोगों का जवाब आता है ईमानदारी से बताओ
एस क्यूआई लैब्स के जितने मैंने आपको
लैब्स का जो बताया था आप लोगों ने कितने
लेसन तक कंप्लीट किए आप में से कितने
लोगों ने कितने लेसन तक किए एकदम स सच सच
बताओ सच्चाई के साथ बताओ कितने लेसन तक की
है सच्चाई के साथ
सच्चाई बता दो
प्लीज एकदम ईमानदारी से सच सच बता देना
भाई स्टूडेंट फोड़ रहे हैं लिंकन में डि
फरोनिक्स अकेडमी के क्या बात है भाई चलो
अच्छी बात है हा हम मतलब ओबवियसली हमें
पता चलता है मैं भी देखता
हूं बहुत सारे स्टूडेंट्स बहुत फोड़ रहे
क्या बात है यह हैकर पियूष गुड गुड गुड
हां मुझे पता है वो डिमांड कहां से आ रही
थी सौम्य तभी मैंने बोला मेरे ऊपर सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग काम नहीं
करेगी ठीक है मेरे पोगर प आ ला हो गया
बहुत बढ़िया हाउ टू फाइ ए ठीक है अरे एसकल
आई वल्नरेबल पैरामीटर ही तो फाइंड करने का
तरीका बताया मैंने यार इतना तरीके बता
दिया आपको फिर भी पूछ रहे हो कैसे फाइंड
करें ऐसे कैसे
चलेगा हा
ए पेन टेस्टिंग का क्लास खत्म हुआ है वाह
बढ़िया
बढ़िया सर मैंने बहुत वीडियोस देखे पर अभी
भी अच्छा रोड मैप नहीं मिल रहा क्या करूं
अरे रोड मैप से तुम लोगों का क्या मतलब
होता है मुझे यह बता दो जरा एक बार रोड
मैप से तुम लोगों का एक्चुअल मतलब क्या
होता है लाइक क्याक टॉपिक्स पढ़ने है वो
या करियर के लिए या क्याक स्टेप्स लेने
हैं सर्टिफिकेशन कौन सी करनी क्या मतलब
होता है यार मुझे पता ही नहीं चलता यार
तुम लोगों का कोई कुछ बोलता है कोई कुछ
बोलता है चलिए तो स्टार्ट करते हैं सेशन
को क्योंकि आप लोग तो मेरी बात मानेंगे
नहीं और मेरी जो ख्वाहिश है उसको पूरी
करेंगे नहीं 100 प्लस लाइफ की बट स्टिल वी
आर स्टार्टिंग एज यूजुअल यहां पे तो सबसे
पहले तो गाइस आप सबको बता देता हूं यहां
पे यह मेरा लिन प्रोफाइल है यू कैन जस्ट
फॉलो मी अप ऑन दिस यूजर हैंडल
linkedin.com
आ स् टेक्निकल नेविगेटर ये हमारी पेज का
लिंकडन प्रोफाइल है डेनिक साइबर
सिक्योरिटी मतलब हमारी कंपनी का लिंकन
प्रोफाइल है इसको आप फॉलो कर लीजिएगा सारी
अपडेट्स सब कुछ आपको यहीं पे मिलेंगी 6000
के आसपास सब फॉलोअर्स हैं इसके अभी वही
साढ़े ये हमारा इंफोसेक डायरी एक न्यू
हमारा एक ऑफलाइन चैप्टर स्टार्ट होने वाला
है एंड दिस चैप्टर इज गोइंग टू मेक सम
ह्यूज अ लाइक अचीवमेंट यूज लाइक जो हमारी
माइल स्टोंस है उनको हम कैच करने वाले हैं
पक ने वाले इसके थ्रू द इंफोसेक डायरी के
थ्रू ऑफलाइन मोड में जो और सबसे पहली जो
स्टार्ट होगी वोह ल्ली नोएडा के साइड हम
स्टार्ट करने वाले हैं इसको फॉलो कर
लीजिएगा आपको अपडेट्स मिल जाएंगी यह हमारी
लिंक
twittersignin.com बॉडी को यूज कर रहे हैं
ठीक है एंड इधर देख लीजिए पहले आप लोग सभी
लोग क्लास पे ध्यान दे दीजिए प्लीज मैं
यहां पे देख रहा हूं चैट में सभी लोग
क्लास पे ध्यान दे दीजिए प्लीज प्लीज
एवरीवन पटना में ऑफलाइन स्टार्ट होगी टाइम
लगेगा पहले दिल्ली नोएडा में हम स्टार्ट
करेंगे एंड देन वी विल मूव टू पटना ओके तो
इसको सेटअप करने का मैंने आपको तरीका बता
दिया गया था बता दिया था ऑलरेडी एंड बहुत
सिंपल सा तरीका था आप सबको पता चल गया
होगा सिंपल जम के थ्रू मैंने बताया था जम
कंट्रोल पैनल को आपको लॉन्च कर देना है रन
एज एडमिन कीजिएगा ज्यादा बढ़िया रहेगा
स्टार्ट पर क्लिक कीजिएगा दोनों अचे एंड
मा एल को स्टार्ट कर दीजिएगा दोनों
स्टार्ट हो जाएंगे राइट नाउ आज की सेशन
थोड़ी शॉर्ट होगी थोड़ी शॉर्ट थोड़ी
शॉर्ट अब यहां पे मैं साइबर फॉक्स ब्राउजर
यूज कर रहा हूं तो मैं इस ब्राउजर को ओपन
कर लेता हूं यहां पे एंड हियर वी हैव द
एक्सटेंशन कॉल्ड हैक बार जिस को कि मैंने
एक मॉडिफाइड वर्जन यूज़ किया है यहां पे
हैक बर मोड को एंड यहां पे हमने उसको
इंस्टॉल कर लिया है एंड हम बग बाउटी के एक
और क्लास एक लर्निंग वीडियो एक लर्निंग
क्लास में है जो कि डे 34 है एंड हमने अब
तक 33 डेज की क्लासेस कर ली हैं बग
बाउंटीज फ्री लाइव ऑनलाइन ट्रेनिंग में जो
कि डेफॉक्स के एक विजन के अंदर आता है आइर
फ्री और मोस्ट अफोर्डेबल एजुकेशन फॉर
एवरीबॉडी या तो फ्री होना चाहिए या तो
सबसे ज्यादा अफोर्डेबल होना चाहिए जिसके
साथ डि फ्रक्स अब तक कायम है आपको डि
फोनिक्स प जितने भी कोर्सेस एंड लाइव
ट्रेनिंग मिलती है
वो डि फ्रक्स के साइट से आपको मोस्ट
अफोर्डेबल फीज या प्राइसेस में मिलती है
आप ऑनलाइन या ऑफलाइन कहीं भी जाके आप
प्राइसेस पता करेंगे एंड उससे आपको कम में
ही यहां मिलेगा एंड क्वालिटी नॉट जस्ट कम
ट्स क्वालिटी थैंक यू
पीयूष चलिए तो यहां पर गाइस आप सबको पता
होगा कि हम इसको एक्सेस कैसे करेंगे भाई
लोकल होस्ट पे करेंगे एंड यहां पे
एसक्यूएल आई लैब मास्टर पे करेंगे एंड
यहां पे एस कए लब मास्टर पे क्लिक करेंगे
हमारे पास इसके चैलेंज आ जाएंगे इसमें
लेसन वाइज चैलेंज आपके दिए गए हैं लेसन 1
2 3 4 5 से लेकर लेसन 22 तक हमने यहां पे
स्टार्टिंग में लेसन व 2 थ ये सब देखा था
लेसन फोर वगैरह ये सब मैंने आपको बोला था
करके लाने के लिए ठीक है क्योंकि ये सब एक
जैसे ही है ऑलमोस्ट मतलब एक जैसे ही थे
ठीक है लाइक लेसन 10 तक आपका क्या था गेट
बेस्ड ही था जो भी था जो भी आपका जो लेसन
जो भी आपके लेसन थे वो गेट बेस थे एंड
उसके बाद लेसन 11 से जो था वो थोड़ा सा
डिफरेंट चेंज हो रहा था क्या पोस्ट बेस्ड
के तरफ हम आ रहे
थे
सॉरी डिफन सर मैंने नासा में सेंसिटिव
डाटा इशू रिपोर्ट किया था ब क्राउड ने उसे
ब्लॉक में ब्लॉकर में डाल ली डालकर आठ दिन
से कुछ रिप्लाई नहीं आया टेंशन मत लो
टेंशन मत लो अगर ब्लॉकर आपके लिए लगा है
तो आपसे वो कुछ रिस्पांस मांग रहे हैं अगर
आप नहीं देंगे तो ब्लॉकर हटेगा नहीं अगर
ब्लॉकर कंपनी के लिए लगाई गई है जो भी वहा
होस्ट है कंपनी का या नासा के लिए तो वो
रिप्लाई करेंगे टेंशन नहीं लेना है ठीक
है बक बाउंट में कंपनी रिवर्ड देने में
प्रॉब्लम करती है क्या नहीं ऐसा कुछ नहीं
है देती भी हा कुछ कुछ कंपनीज रिवॉर्ड में
प्रॉब्लम आती है कुछ जो जो कुछ ऐसी कंपनी
होती है ना जो प्रोग्राम होते जो सही नहीं
होते वो करती है ठीक है उन आती है तो चलिए
आज हम एसल मैप के एक अलग कांसेप्ट पर बात
करेंगे पोस्ट बेस का अब मैंने ना आपको
प्रीवियस क्लास में आपको बताया हुआ था
ऑलरेडी एसकल इंजेक्शन के अलग अलग टाइप्स
के बारे में ठीक है तो मैंने आपको बताया
था एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन के टाइप्स के बारे
में एक मैंने बताया था आपको गेट
बेस्ड बताया था आपको पोस्ट बेस्ड आपको
हेडर
बेस्ड ठीक है
और आपको बताया था कुकी बेस्ड ये सब बताए
थे आपको तो हमने गेट बेस्ड तो बहुत सारे
कर लिए थे एग्जांपल के थ्रू यहां पे पोस्ट
बेस की बारी है पोस्ट का हम एक थोड़ा
कंसेप्ट समझेंगे क्योंकि ये कंसेप्ट बहुत
ज्यादा जरूरी है क्योंकि आपको यूजुअली जब
एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन मिलेगा ना तो गेट और
पोस्ट बेस बहुत ज्यादा मिलेंगे हेडर बेस
भी मिलेगा और कुकी बेस भी मिलेगा नॉट दैट
मच बट स्टिल दैट यू कैन फाइंड तो मिलेगा
आपको उसके बाद मैंने आपको टाइप्स में बताए
थे एसक्यूएल के एक एरर एरर बेस्ड बताया
था ठीक है आपको अगर याद होगा वी सॉ एरर
बेस यूनियन
बेस्ड एंड
ब्लाइंड ब्लाइंड में हमने बुलियन देखा था
एंड एक और क्या देखा था टाइम बुलियन एंड
टाइम बेस देखा था ठीक है यह चीजें कर देखी
थी ये सिंपल सा तो गेट बेस्ट हमने कवर
किया था पोस्ट बेस की तरफ हम थोड़ा मूव ऑन
कर रहे हैं और उसके लिए हम चलेंगे लेसन
नंबर 11 पे क्यों क्योंकि ये पोस्ट एरर
बेस्ड सिंगल कोड स्ट्रिंग एक लैब है जिस
पर की हम थोड़ा सा हाथ की सफाई करेंगे अब
देखो यहां पे इसको हमने ओपन किया कुछ इस
तरीके से ओपन हुआ ठीक है अब देखो यहां पे
दिक्कत एक क्या है ना आपको थोड़ी ना
कांसेप्ट को समझनी है देखो ये कांसेप्ट से
है ओनली आपको ये समझना पड़ेगा कि दीज आर
जस्ट अ
कांसेप्ट यह आपकी प्रैक्टिस नहीं है इस पे
तो आप प्रैक्टिस करेंगे तो कांसेप्ट
समझेंगे प्रैक्टिस जब आप करेंगे तो व आप
रियल प वेबसाइट्स पे रियल टारगेट्स पे
ट्राई करेंगे सेम कांसेप्ट को ट्राई
करेंगे ऐसा नहीं है कि ये लैब है तो यह
कुछ नहीं है रियल है वही सब कुछ है रियल
में कहां से क्या डालोगे रियल में कि
तुम्हें मिलेगा क्या करोगे कैसे पहचानोगे
गेट बेस्ड है पोस्ट बेस्ड है क्या है एरर
है यूनियन है बुलियन है टाइम है क्या भाई
क्या तो ऐसे समझ में आनी चाहिए अब देखो
पोस्ट और गेट में कितना डिफरेंस आ जाएगा
ना तुमको अभी समझ में आएगा तब तुम समझोगे
कि अरे ऐसा क्या ऐसा था क्या यह चीज हो गई
क्या यह तुमको समझ में आएगा ठीक
है
ओके ओके गाइस इधर ध्यान दे दीजिए सबसे
पहले ओके कुकी बेस सबसे इजी लगा हा सही
बात है इजी है यार इजी है चलिए अब हम यहां
पर लेसन 11 प आ गए लोड यूआरएल को लोड कर
देते इसकी थोड़ी सी मैं जूम इन कर देता
हूं इसकी फंट को अब हम यहां पे पहले हम
क्या करते थे इसको थोड़ा समझिए और अब कैसे
करेंगे उसको समझिए देखो पहले हम क्या कर
देते थे लेसन 11 था क्वेश्चन मार्क आईडी इ
ट 1 एक पैरामीटर देते थे राइट एंड इसको हम
एग्जीक्यूट करते थे यहां पे एग्जीक्यूट कर
रहे हैं कुछ नहीं हो रहा क्यों क्योंकि
यहां लैब में आपसे कहीं कोई आईडी पैरामीटर
डालने का कुछ आ ही नहीं रहा कि आईडी डालो
कुछ डालो यहां सिर्फ एक यूजर नेम फील्ड है
एक पासवर्ड फील्ड मैंने आपको बताया था
पोस्ट बेस्ड कहां मिलेंगे आपको लॉगइन
फॉर्म्स पे साइन अप फॉर्म्स पे कांटेक्ट
फॉर्म्स पे एक्सेट्रा एक्सेट्रा
जग प मिलेंगे ये पर्टिकुलर वने बिलिटी जो
कि पोस्ट बेस एसकल आई है अब मुझे यहां पर
यूजर नेम है अब मैं यूजर नेम की जगह पर
क्या डालता हूं एडमिन डालता
हूं पासवर्ड की जगह पर मैं डाल देता हूं
पासवर्ड यह डालता ठीक है अब मैं यहां पर
सबमिट करता हूं सबमिट जैसे मैंने किया अब
यहां आ रहा है लॉगिन अटेम्प्ट
फेल्ड ठीक है लॉगिन अटेम्प्ट
फेल्ड ऐसा क्या हुआ भाई अब मैं यहां पर
क्या करता हूं यूजर नेम एडमिन डालता हूं
पासवर्ड भी एडमिन ही डालता हूं लॉगिन करता
हूं सबमिट यह क्या हुआ य लॉगिन नेम एडमिन
पासवर्ड एडमिन सक्सेसफुली लगड इन यहां आ
रहा है कि लॉग इन हो चुके हैं कुछ समझ में
नहीं आया ना समझ में मतलब दिमाग से बाहर
चला गया कुछ समझ में नहीं आ रहा कि भाई हो
क्या रहा हैय अब ऐसे केसेस में ना ऐसे
केसेस में हमारे पास एक चीज दिमाग में आती
है क्या आती है कि हम इसको पहले पहले जैसी
एरर चेकिंग ही कर लेते हैं और फिर देखते
हैं क्या कर सकते हैं तो यहां यूजरनेम
फील्ड में मैंने फॉरवर्ड स्लश दे दिया जो
हम चेक करते थे फॉरवर्ड स्ल दिया एंड
सबमिट क्लिक किया जैसे ही मैंने सबमिट
किया एज सून आई सबमिटेड या यहां पर मैं
इसको सिलेक्ट करूंगा यहां पर यह एरर
है व्ट टाइब ऑफ एरर इट इज यू हैव एन एरर
इन र एल सिंटेक्स चक द मैनुअल ट कस्प टू
यो म डीबी सवर वर्जन फॉर द राइट सिंटेक्स
टू यूज नियर स्लश यानी कि फॉरव
स्लश एंड उसके बाद सिंगल को एंड द पासवर्ड
इ इक्वल टू लिमिट 0 एट लाइन व व्ट एवर
सिंगल कोट तो दिमाग में आया सिंगल कोट
सिंगल कोट आ गया तो अब हम क्या करेंगे
सिंगल कोट सिंगल कोट के बाद अब हमें यहां
पर सिंगल कोट डाल दिया भैया सिंगल कोट
हमने अच्छी बात है यार सिंगल कोड डाल दिया
बहुत
बढ़िया ओके चलो एक काम कर लेते
हैं ट सिंगल एक सेकंड
इसको मैं
ना अरे यार इसको मैं यहां पर एक सेकंड एक
सेकंड एक सेकंड एसकल आई एसकल आई इसको
रिसेट कर देते हैं एक्यूट कर देते
हैं एी
क्यूट अरे
भैया कहां गया भाई चैलेंज 11 है ना 11 प आ
गए हा अब य पर सिंगल कोट सॉरी सिंगल कोट
सिंगल कोट दिया सबमिट किया एरर आ गई तो हम
फॉरवर्ड स्लैश देते हैं सबमिट करते हैं
हमें एरर आ गई और हमें क्या पता चला कि इस
फॉरवर्ड स्लैश के बाद यहां पर सिंगल कोड
है तो चलिए अब यहां पे सिंगल कोड दे देते
हैं और पहले हम क्या करते थे गाइस गेट बेज
वाले में गेट बेस्ड वाले में जब हमें एरर
को सॉल्व करनी होती थी हमें एरर को टू
सॉल्व एरर टू सॉल्व एरर इन गेट बेस्ड
वी वी यूज क्या करते थे भाई माइनस माइनस
प्लस यह करते थे ना यहां पर भी हम क्या कर
देते हैं माइनस माइनस प्लस करते हैं और
सबमिट करते हैं देखते हैं क्या बात है भाई
एरर सॉल्व नहीं हुई यहां पर एरर सॉल्व हुई
ही नहीं अब यहां पर क्या करेंगे भाई मैंने
तो यार बिल्कुल सही किया मैंने कहा कुछ
गलत किया मैंने सिंगल कोड दिया मैंने यहां
पर स्पेस दिया माइनस माइनस प्लस दिया यही
तो किया एरर सॉल्व करने के लिए नाउ व्ट वी
हैव टू डू फ उसको छोड़ के बाकी सब लोग
बताएंगे
जिसने ला सॉल्व किया उसको वो नहीं बोलेगा
कुछ बताइ वट वी विल
डू
आहा चलिए यहां पर पोस्ट बेस्ड में हम क्या
करेंगे हम क्या करते हैं वी इन पोस्ट
बेस्ड
वी
यूज वी यूज माइनस माइनस
स्पेस और हैश
इंटेड इंस्टेड ऑफ माइनस माइनस
प्लस यहां पर पोस्ट बेस में हम माइनस
माइनस स्पेस यूज करते हैं या तो हम उसकी
जगह सिर्फ हैश यूज करते हैं दोनों ही आप
यूज कर सकते हैं जी हां यानी कि यहां पर
माइनस माइनस प्लस के जगह पर माइनस माइनस
के बाद एक सिंपल स्पेस प्रेस कर दीजिए कुछ
लिखेगा नहीं ओबवियसली स्पेस है एंड सबमिट
कीजिए आपकी एरर सॉल्व हो चुकी
है या तो हम अगेन सिंगल कोट माइनस माइनस
प्लस के जगह पर इसको हटा के सिर्फ हैश लिख
देंगे और यहां पर सबमिट करेंगे वैसे भी
आपकी एरर सॉल्व हो
जाएगी यह आपको समझ में आया पोस्ट बेस में
एरर कैसे सॉल्व करनी
है एवरीवन गट क्या करना है पोस्ट बेज में
माइनस माइनस प्लस के जगह प क्या यूज करना
है कौन सी दो चीजें यूज कर सकते हैं जल्दी
बताइए मैं चैट में देख रहा हूं जल्दी
बताइए फटाफट क्या यूज कर सकते
हैं बताओ जल्दी फटाफट हली हली फास्ट
गाइस रिप्लाई
यार या माइनस माइनस प्लस और हैश माइनस
माइनस प्लस और
हैश क्या बात है रॉयल चैलेंजर गुड ठीक है
तो हम यहां पर जो एरर हमें आ रही थी उसको
हमने सिंगल कोट एरर के बाद वाली एंड फिर
उसके बाद हैश करके हम हैश ही यूज करेंगे
माइनस माइनस स्पेस क्यों यूज करेंगे इतना
लंबा हम हैश यूज करेंगे सबमिट किया हमने
इसको एरर को सॉल्व कर दिया एरर को जब
सॉल्व कर लिया तो अब प्रोसेस जो है हमारा
कुछ सिमिलर सा हो जाएगा पहले जो हमने किया
था ठीक है थोड़ा डिफरेंस रहेगा बट स्टिल
कुछ सिमिलर आपका हो जाएगा अब क्या हो
जाएगा सिमिलरिटी क्या है भैया ये देख
लीजिए अब हम यहां पर अगेन यूनियन
ऑल सेलेक्ट यूनियन ऑल सेलेक्ट यह चीज हमने
डाली यूनियन ऑल
सिलेक्ट यह चीज डाली सही है यह यूनियन ऑल
सेलेक्ट सही है
गाइस बताओ
जल्दी टाटा द टॉप जी प्लीज डोंट मैसेज एनी
अननेसेसरी थिंग इन द चैट
प्लीज ठीक है
यह बताइए जल्दी से यूनियन अब यह सही डाला
हमने यूनियन ऑल सिलेक्ट या कुछ और डाल
सकते हैं यहां पर कुछ और डालना
था बता दीजिए प्लीज जल्दी जल्दी जल्दी
जल्दी
जल्दी ऑर्डर भाई चलो बढ़िया चलो यह
सीक्वेंस तो याद है कम से कम पहले हम क्या
करेंगे गाइस ऑर्डर बाय तो ऑर्डर बाय एंड
वही वन ऑर्डर बाय वन सबमिट किया कोई एरर
नहीं आई ऑर्डर बाय टू सबमिट किया कोई एरर
नहीं आए ऑर्डर बाय थ्री सबमिट किया एंड ज
थ्री थर्ड पे ही थर्ड पे हमें क्या मिला
भाई थर्ड पे हमें मिल गया अननोन कॉलम थ्री
इन ऑर्डर क्लॉज अननोन कॉलम थ थर्ड पे ही
चलिए ये भी बात हो गई थर्ड पे यानी कि
हमारे पास नंबर ऑफ कॉलम्स कितने है थर्ड
पे एरर आई है मुझे अननोन कॉलम थ नंबर ऑफ
कॉलम्स कितने जल्दी बताओ जल्दी जल्दी
जल्दी जल्दी अननोन कॉलम्स थ्री टोटल नंबर
ऑफ कॉलम्स कितने हैं टू है
ना टू है बस बढ़िया एकदम बढ़िया टू है
हमारे पास टोटल नंबर ऑफ कॉलम जो है वो टू
है तो अब हम क्या करेंगे
यूनियन
ऑल सेलेक्ट यूनियन ऑल सिलेक्ट
टू ठीक है यह हमने किया सबमिट किया एंड
जैसे ही हमने सबमिट किया यूनियन ऑल
सेलेक्ट वनटू यू गॉट सक्सेसफुल लॉग इन एंड
यहां पे लॉगिन नेम जो है आपको यहां पर दिख
रहा होगा लॉगिन नेम वन लॉगिन नेम टू यहां
प्रिंट होके आ चुका यानी कि वन एंड टू ये
आपके कॉलम है वन एंड टू क्या है आपके कॉलम
है टाटा द टॉप जीी आपको थोड़ी देर के लिए
जाना पड़ेगा यहां से ड्यू टू द स्पैम
एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी मैं नहीं चाहता किसी को
बिना मतलब का वो करूं बट स्टिल आप एक
मैसेज को ना 50 बार कर रहे हैं तो थोड़ा
सा डिस्टरबेंस हो रहा है ठीक है तो थोड़ी
देर के लिए आप रहिए फिर आइएगा दोबारा चैट
में ठीक है
चलिए ओके सो यहां पे हमारे पास टू कॉलम्स
आ गए तो बहुत बढ़िया अब यहां पे हमें वन
कॉलम पे क्या चाहिए भैया हमें वर्जन चाहिए
डेटाबेस का हमने वर्जन लिखा एंड यहां पे
सबमिट किया सबमिट करते ही हमें वर्जन मिल
गया योर लॉगिन नेम वर्जन जो है ये रहा
10.1.3 मारया डीबी समझ गए बस सिंपल सा
फंडा है तो वी गॉट द डेटाबेस वर्जन बस बात
खत्म इतना ही करना है भाई इतना ही दिखाना
है आपको जब आप रिपोर्ट वगैरह किसी को एई
वगैरह करोगे ना कहीं पे फाइंड इतना दिखा
दोगे यहीं से उनका दिमाग हिल जाएगा कि अरे
भाई क्या हुआ डेटाबेस कैसे निकल गया इनका
नाम कैसे निकल गया यह कैसे निकल गया खत्म
टाटा बाय बाय यह सब हो
गई अब भाई यहां पे मुझे वन के जगह पे
मैंने क्या किया वर्जन लिख दिया चलो टू के
जगह पे मैंने क्या किया क्योंकि दोनों
कॉलम अफेक्टेड है डेटाबेस एंड यहां पे मैं
मैंने सबमिट कर दिया तो यहां पर क्या हो
गया दोनों देखे दोनों आ गए लॉगिन नेम
डेटाबेस आ गई पासवर्ड में डेटाबेस सॉरी
लॉगिन नेम वर्जन आ गया थैंक यू बालाजी एंड
यहां पासवर्ड में सिक्योरिटी आपका डेटाबेस
का नाम आ गया ए सिंपल एट ठीक है यानी कि
हम पोस्ट बेस में ना गाइस हमेशा देखो
पोस्ट बेस में हम क्या करते हैं हम पोस्ट
बेस में
हमेशा माइनस माइनस प्लस के जगह
पर ठीक है माइनस माइनस प्लस य आपका है
इसके जगह पर हमने क्या
किया यूज हैश किया एंड हमेशा हम प्लस के
जगह पर स्पेस यूज करते
हैं जब भी कहीं पर आपको प्लस दिखेगा वहां
पर आपको स्पेस यूज करना
है इसीलिए माइनस माइनस प्लस इक्वल टू है
होता है या तो इ इक्वल टू माइनस माइनस
स्पेस होता है यह चीज होती है
गॉट
इट साइड लोड नहीं होगी भाई यही तो बात है
साइड लोड की बात नहीं है यहां पे यही तो
बात है यार यही तो दिमाग लगाना है दिस इज
नॉट अबाउट द साइड लोडिंग इट्स अबाउट द
कंसेप्ट कि आप क्या लगड इन दिखा रहा है
मतलब वी आर ट्रू हम सही हैं अब इसको ना
मैं एक और रिलेशन में आपको थोड़ा सा
क्लियर करूंगा बुलियन वाले में कि क्या है
यह क्या प्रोसेस चल रहा है ठीक है यह आपको
समझ में आ जाएगा थोड़ी देर थोड़ी देर में
ठीक है तो हमने यहां पे सक्सेसफुल लॉगइन
कर लिया यानी कि वी आर गुड टू गो हमारा
बिलकुल सही है और हमें यहां पे इसका डिटेल
मिल गया अगर यह फॉल्स रहता लॉगिन नहीं कर
पाते तो हमें यह डिटेल नहीं मिलती तो वी
गॉट द डेटाबेस नेम वर्जन जो भी है एंड
डेटाबेस नेम यह हमें मिल चुका ठीक है अब
मुझे अब मुझे डेटाबेस की लिस्ट चाहिए यह
तो बस एक डेटाबेस निकला सिक्योरिटी मान लो
अब मुझे चाहिए पूरी डेटाबेस की लिस्ट तो
उसके लिए क्या करेंगे उसके लिए क्या
करेंगे बताओ सेम हमने कमांड डाला अब हम
क्या करेंगे यहां पर यूनियन ऑल सिलेक्ट वन
के जगह पर हम यहां पर यूनियन बेस्ट पर
जाएंगे ओबवियसली यूनियन बेस्ट वी आर
करेंटली
डाइंग डेटाबेस पर जाएंगे एंड यहां पर
डेटाबेस नेम्स का कमांड है तो पहले इस
वाले फील्ड को क्लियर आउट कर देते हैं
ताकि यहां पर कमांड हमें मिल जाए यूनियन
बेस प जाते हैं डेटाबेस नेम्स पर जाएंगे
डेटाबेस नेम्स प जाएंगे तो यह कमांड हमारे
पास एक आ जाएगा वी गट दिस कमांड
ठीक है वी गट
दिस ठीक
है कट अब यहां पर इस कमांड को हमने य से
कॉपी किया और इसको वन के जगह पर डाल देंगे
तो हो जाएगा ना वन के जगह डालेंगे वन के
जगह हमने इसको यहां पर पेस्ट कर दिया ठीक
है भाई अब हमारी पूरी जो कमांड बनी है वह
यह बनी है देख
लो यह बनी है सिंगल कोट स्पेस यूनियन ऑल
सेलेक्ट यह पूरा जो कमांड जनरेट हुआ वन के
जगह पर कॉमा टू एंड हैश सही है भाई सही है
एवरीवन यह कमांड हो गई अब हम इसको यहां पर
सबमिट करते हैं सबमिट करते ही हमारे पास
डेटाबेस के नेम्स नहीं आए हमारे पास एरर आ
गई ऐसा क्यों हुआ हमने तो सही किया यूनियन
बेस पर
गए ठीक है पियूष को छोड़ के बाकी लोग बता
सकते हैं यूनियन बेस पर गए डेटाबेस पर गए
डेटाबेस नेम्स पर गए कमांड आई यहां हमने
कर दिया तो फिर यह एरर क्यों आ गई मतलब यह
समझ नहीं आया वई दिस एरर
केम
बताइए बताइए सभी लोग बताइए
प्लीज हैश सॉल्व द एरर शश दिया है यह रहा
ना कमांड इसमें हैश तो
हैय इसमें एक छोटा सा कांसेप्ट है ठीक है
एक छोटा कांसेप्ट है जो मैंने अभी आपको
थोड़ी देर पहले ही बताया था जस्ट अ लिटिल
बिट ऑफ कांसेप्ट वही कांसेप्ट है
छोटी-छोटी कांसेप्ट आप ध्यान में रखेंगे
और उसको एग्जीक्यूट करेंगे तो आपका हर काम
होता चला जाएगा बग बाउंटीज में वो काम अगर
आप नहीं करेंगे तो आपका एरर आएगा और आपको
लगेगा मैं गलत कर रहा हूं मैंने आपको
थोड़ी देर पहले बताया था जस्ट अ लिटिल बिट
अर्लिया कि पोस्ट बेस में प्लस के जगह पे
आप स्पेस का यूज करेंगे ठीक है प्लस के
जगह स्पेस यूज करेंगे अब यहां जो हमारे
पास यह ग्रुप ये जो कमांड बन के आई है ना
ये वाला ग्रुप कॉन कट का यह वाला मतलब
डेटाबेस वाली इस कमांड को जब मैं कॉपी
करके यहां कमांड में आए और इसको मैं एक
न्यू टैब में य पेस्ट करता हूं आप ध्यान
देना कि यहां पर प्लस आपको दिख रहा है हर
जगह प्लस लगा हुआ
है यह किस टाइप का एरर है पोस्ट बेस्ट
सिंगल
कोट ठीक है यह किस टाइप का यह है यहां
देखो ना यार
पोस्ट बेस्ड सिंगल कोट वाली ठीक
है चलिए तो यहां पर आपको समझ में आ रहा है
कि सब जगह प्लस है अब मैं क्या करूंगा इन
प्लस को स्पेस से रिप्लेस कर दूंगा फिर
ट्राई करूंगा चलिए भाई तो बढ़िया है अच्छी
बात है यार तो व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू डू वी
आर गोइंग टू रिप्लेस ओनली ठीक है तो
रिप्लेस करने के लिए क्या करेंगे भाई फाइल
में
चलेंगे एडिट में चलेंगे रिप्लेस प जाएंगे
रिप्लेस प्लस को रिप्लेस प्लस को यहां प
प्लस को रिप्लेस करना है किससे किससे करना
है यहां पर स्पेस दे दो स्पेस से रिप्लेस
ल रिप्लेस ल कर दिया रिप्लेस ल कर दिया
बढ़िया अब हमारे पास जो यहां पर ये मिली
हुई है यह जो कमांड इसको कॉपी कर लेते
हैं एंड कॉपी कर लिया
एंड इसको हम यहां पर डाल देंगे कहां पर
डालना है ये
वाली वन के जगह प ठीक है तो वन के जगह
पर हमने क्या करना है यूनियन ऑल सिलेक्ट
एंड वन के जगह पर हमने ये कमांड डाल दी
स्पेस के साथ स्टार्टिंग में देख लेते हैं
सब सही
है
हां ठीक है हां अब सबमिट करके देखते हैं
सबमिट एंड देखो सबमिट करते ही वी गट द
डेटा बेसेस कौन से इंफॉर्मेशन स्कीमा माय
सीक्वल परफॉर्मेंस स्कीमा पीएचपी मा एडमिन
सिक्योरिटी टेस्ट एक्सेट्रा एक्सेट्रा
एक्सेट्रा समझ में
आया गॉट इट यह हमें यहां पे एक कांसेप्ट
से बस समझ में आ गया होगा कि यहां पर हमने
यह चीज कर ली क्योंकि हमने अब इस वाले
पेलोड को यहां पे स्पेस वाले से रिप्लेस
कर दिया प्लस के जगह से स्पेस जितने प्लस
है उसको हटा दिए एंड उसमें स्पेस लगा दिया
बस ट्स इट अब यह क्या है ना यार यह तुम
कहीं पे लाइव हंट नहीं कर
तुम बस दिमाग में डाल रहे हो कि भाई पोस्ट
बेस में इसे होता है गेट बेस में इसे होता
है सिंगल कोट ऐसे डबल कोस्ट ऐसे डबल
इंजेक्शन होता है यह होता है वो होता है
फलाना डिकाना यह सब तुम कर रहे हो
बस यही समझने की बात है नहीं समझोगे भाई
दिक्कत होगी समझोगे एक बार समझ गए दिमाग
में घुस गया स्कल इंजेक्शन क्लियर हो
जाएगा उसके बाद तो भाई टूल्स एंड
टेक्निक्स ही है यह मैनुअल वाली चीज तुम
बहुत कम करोगे तुम खुद ही बहुत कम करोगे
अब मैं आपको एक चीज बताता हूं जो तुम काम
यहां कर रहे हो यह चीज मैनुअली कर रहे हो
ना एसक्यूएल मैप यह सारे काम बैकग्राउंड
में ना ऑटोमेटिक करता है यह सारे काम एसकल
मैप बैकग्राउंड में ऑटोमेटिक करता है यह
सब आपको करने की जरूरत नहीं पड़ेगी ए मैप
के साथ जो एल मैप टूल है
हमारा यू डोंट नीड टू डू ल दिस स्टफ यह
स्टफ करने की नीड आपको है ही नहीं एक्चुअल
में टूल्स आपके लिए कर रही है एल मैप
बेस्ट वन ऑफ द बेस्ट टूल ही है कई बार
होता है मैनुअल आप करोगे तो कई बार लाइक
थोड़ा डिफरेंस कभी-कभी आ जाता है आपके
रिजल्ट में कई बार कुछ चीजें मैनुअली पकड़
में आ जाती है ऑटोमेटेड वे में नहीं आ
पाती है बट मोस्ट ऑफ द केसेस में ऑटोमेशन
में आपका सारा काम हो जाता है एसक्यूएल
मैप ही जो है वो यूज की जाती है बहुत सारे
रिसर्चस के द्वारा ठीक है मैनुअल भी यूज
किया जाता है वो भी यूज किया जाता है बट
वो टूल आपके लिए कर ही है लेकिन वो टूल कर
तो रही है भाई लेकिन टूल को तो समझना है
ना यार टूल को मैं पहचानू टूल को मैं
जानूं टूल तो ठीक टूल मैं पहचानू
ना बस यही
चीज ठीक है समझ में आ गया
होगा समझ में आ गया होगा मैनुअल मैनुअल
बेटर होता है कहने के लिए बिल्कुल बात है
सही बात है पियूष मैनुअल इज ऑलवेज बेटर
कहने के लिए और बहुत सारे लोग बोलते हैं
कि मैनुअल बहुत अच्छा है मैनुअल इज द
बेस्ट अप्रोच ये वो लेकिन जब वो बग बाउंट
हंटिंग करेंगे या जो भी रिसर्चस होते वो ट
ऑटोमेशन एंड फुल ऑन ऑटोमेशन में चलती है
एक तरह से अगर आप ऑटोमेशन का यूज नहीं
करेंगे और सिर्फ आप मैनुअल में रह जाएंगे
तो पता चलेगा कि जो लेबिलिटी आपको आज
खोजनी थी वो मतलब जो आपको दो दिन में
मिलनी थी वो एक दिन पहले ही किसी और ने
निकाल के वो दे दिया तो कोई फायदा नहीं है
आपको मैनुअल किंग नहीं बनना आप लोगों को
मैं बात को मेरी समझो मैं ये नहीं बोल रहा
मैनुअल इज नॉट अ गुड थिंग मैनुअल अप्रोच
इज नॉट अ बैड नॉट अ गुड थिंग ऑटोमेशन इज
ऑलवेज गुड ऐसा नहीं बोल रहा मैनुअल इ
ऑलवेज द बेस्ट वन बट आपको आगे रहना है
बाकी रिसर्चर से वैलिड बग फाइंड करने
हैं वैलिड चीजें फाइंड करनी है जल्दी
फाइंड करना है रिपोर्ट करनी
है समझ में आ
गया समझ में आया आप लोगों को मैं क्या
कहना चाह रहा
हूं सर बहुत हार्ड लग रहा है यह चीज
बहुत हार्ड लग रहा है यह चीज कैसे
करूं अच्छा ठीक है बहुत हार्ड लग रहा है
एक बंदे ने बोला कि सर बहुत हार्ड लग रहा
है यह चीज कैसे करूं और देखो नाम भी ऐसा
रखते हैं कि मैं यह भी नहीं बोल सकता कि
कौन बोल रहा है यह बात कि बहुत हार्ड लग
रहा है देखो इसका नाम है भिखमंगा
गेमर भीख मंगया गेमर इसका नाम है अब मैं
इसका नाम क्या मतलब कैसे बोलू मैं इसको कि
कौन किसको हाड लग रहा है नाम भी तो कम से
कम यार रियल या कुछ बढ़िया रख के लख यार
कि कम से कम पढ़ पाऊं मैं उसको यार
भिखमंगा गेमर बोल रहे हो मैं क्या बोलूं
तो भिखमंगा जो गेमर है उसको हार्ड लग रहा
है हार्ड अगर लग रहा है तो बस इतना सोचो
कि यह एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन य एसक्यूएल आई
लैब्स यह कंप्यूटर ये डिज बाइनरी डिजिट्स
ये सब ह्यूमंस ने क्रिएट किया है ह्यूमन
के दिमाग ने आपका भी दिमाग वही है सबका
दिमाग एक ही होता है ट्रेंड और अनट्रेंड
की डिफरेंस होती है फर्क होता है ट्रेंड
और अनट्रेंड दो चीजें होती है दिमाग के
ऊपर जिसका ट्रेंड हो गया वो परफेक्ट हैड
अनट्रेंड है उस को ट्रेन करना पड़ता है तो
ट्रेन योर माइंड टू ग्रैब दज थिंग्स एंड
देन द थिंग्स विल बी इजियर फॉर यू ठीक
है मैनुअल इजी लग रहा
है हां मैनुअल इजी लग रहा
है व्हाई वी यूज दिस यूनियन बेस अटैक
इंस्टेंट आप ये मैनुअल में आप कर सकते हो
हैज टूल भी यूज कर सकते हो कोई बड़ी बात
नहीं है हैवी भी आल्सो यू कैन यूज बट एसल
मैप इज फार मच बेटर देन हाईवेज आई
थिंक ठीक
है वो डेमो होगा लेट्स क्राफ्ट डेमो डाटा
होगा या टेस्ट डाटा होगा या डटा डिलीटेड
होंगी डेटाबेस से
इनकोडिंग के लिए यूज नहीं है इनकोडिंग के
लिए आकाश यूज नहीं है
वो इनकोडिंग के लिए यूज नहीं है वो ऑपरेटर
है जो कि आपको पोस्ट में उसकी
रिक्वायरमेंट उसको स्पेस से आपको डिनोट
करना पड़ता है नहीं तो फिर वह उसको नहीं
लेगा सिंपल सा फंडा है वो कंसीडर ही नहीं
करेगा या तो आप हैश यूज कीजिए उसके जगह
कमेंटिंग के लिए ज पोस्ट बेस में करते हैं
तो कमेंटिंग जो है या तो आप हैश कीजिएगा
या तो आप स्पेस आपको यूज करना पड़ेगा तभी
वो लेगा ठीक
है ओके चलिए तो यहां पर हमारे पास डेटाबेस
की लिस्ट आ चकी सॉरी डेटाबेस की लिस्ट आ
चुकी है वी गट द डेटाबेस लिस्ट हियर राइट
नाउ अगेन सेम चीज है अगेन सेम चीज है मैं
क्या कहना चाह रहा हूं कि मैं अब इसमें
क्या चाहता हूं चलो भैया मेरा कमांड डाला
ठीक है मेरा यह कमांड डाल दिया एक काम
करता हूं ना मैं यार ये प्रीवियस कमांड जो
है इस कमांड को यहां से यूनियन ऑल
सेलेक्ट इसको रिमूव करते हैं नटू है ना
चलिए यहां से इसको कॉपी
किया देखो आज की स्ट्रेंथ कम है ना
क्योंकि लोगों के दिमाग में क्या होता है
कि बहुत इजी चीज चाहिए टफ चीज लोग जल्दी
देख नहीं पाते बेचारे ठीक है और अरे आज आज
क्या मतलब आज तुम लोग यहां बहुत कम प्रज
क्या एग्जिट पोल देख रहे हो क्या सब लोग
सब लोग एग्जिट पोल देखने में बिजी है लग
रहा है प्राइम मिनिस्टर कौन बनेगा इंडिया
का मुझे लग रहा है उसी में सब बिजी है यार
इसलिए सब भागे पड़े
हैं
चलिए अच्छा यह बता दो यार कौन बन रहा है
प्राइम मिनिस्टर इंडिया
का यह बता दो चलो एक एग्जिट पोल हम लोग भी
ले लेते हैं क्या लग रहा है आप लोगों को
कौन जीत रही है जीत रही है कांग्रेस जीत
रही है यानी कि एनडीए अलायंस जीत रही है
एक तरह से बोलो या इंडिया ब्लॉक इंडी
ब्लॉक जो है व जीत रही है क्या लग रहा
है सर मे को आज फर्स्ट बग मिला आफ्टर
सिक्स मंथ्स क्या बात है फ्लेक्स बॉक्स
गेमिंग फ्लेक्स बॉय गेमिंग कांग्रेचुलेशन
ऑन र फ फर्स्ट बग वेरी वेरी मेनी मेनी
कांग्रेचुलेशन
बाप रे सब लोग बीजेपी बोल रहे हैं भाय
क्या बात है बीजेपी ज्यादा है यहां
पे हां
बट एग्जिट पोल से ऑलमोस्ट क्लियर हो जाता
है मुझे तो इमरान खान
चाहिए जेल से बाहर क्या बात है
यार आप किसको वोट दिए अरे बाप रे यह
क्वेश्चन मत पूछो यार ऐसे नहीं पूछते
क्वेश्चन चलो ठीक है यहां पर मोस्टली वही
है ठीक है
बट यार तुम लोग गलत कर रहे हो यार तुम लोग
मतलब एक बार एक बार तुम्हें राहुल गांधी
को पीएम बनाना चाहिए यार तुम लोग राहुल
गांधी को एक बार भी मौका नहीं दे रहे हो
सब एक बार उनको मौका तो दो यार कम से
कम कब से वो ख्वाब देख रहे हैं पीएम बनने
का ब तुम लोग देते ही नहीं हो यार भारत की
जनता दे ही नहीं रही उनको मौका यार समझ
में नहीं आ रहा भारत की जनता क्या चाहती
है उनसे एक
बार भारत की जनता उनको मौका क्यों नहीं दे
रही है मुझे आज तक समझ में नहीं आया यार
इतने यार मस्त हटे कट्टे हैं यार पढ़े
लिखे हैं इतना समझदार
है अरे
भाई मैंने कहां कुछ बोला अपने कि मैंने
कहा किसको वोट दिया है मैं अपनी मैं वोट
अपना बताता नहीं हूं किसको दिया है वो तो
नहीं
बताऊंगा अरे भाई साहब
बट बट यार मेरे को दुख लगता है ना यार
मेरे को दुख लग मान लो मैं ही पीएम
कैंडिडेट के लिए खड़ा हूं यार चार पांच
बार से खड़ा हो रहा हूं तुम लोग मुझे जिता
ही नहीं रहे हो तो मैं तो रोंगा बैठ के
यार मैं तो साइड में क्राई करूंगा ना
रोंगा मैं तो यार मुझे तो अच्छा नहीं
लगेगा आई विल फील
बैड आई विल फील सो सड यार ट आईम नॉट
बिकमिंग प्राइम
मिनिस्टर अरे बोलो कासिम बोलो कोई नाराज
नहीं होगा कोई नाराज नहीं होगा किसी
पार्टी को लेकर नाराज कोई नहीं होगा टेंशन
नहीं लेने का ठीक
है चलो एक तो आया कांग्रेस वाला वाह
गुड अरे भाई आ रहा है भाई
कांग्रेस कांग्रेस ही आ रहा है
भाई मेरे को वोट दोगे वाह यार क्या बात है
मैं पीएम बनने की होड में आता हूं यार मैं
भी जल्दी पीएम बनूंगा
फिर एक और कांग्रेस वाह क्या बात है
भाई कुछ भी हो कोई बात नहीं जाने दो
प्राइम मिनिस्टर इस बार भी आपके मोदी ही
बनने वाले हैं मुझे पता है चाहे वो सट्टा
बाजार से लेके और कहीं तक की बातें कर लो
ऑलमोस्ट उन्हीं का आ रहा है तो आई डोंट
थिंक की कांग्रेस आने वाली है बट वो तो फथ
जून को ही पता चलेगा कि क्या होने वाला है
ठीक है चलिए मेन पॉइंट प आ जाते
हैं सर कांग्रेस को दिए हैं पक्का यह तो
तुम कैसे बोल दोगे जब तक मैं ना बताऊं कि
मैंने बीजेपी को दिया है कि कांग्रेस को
दिया है यह जब तक मैं ना बोलू कोई नहीं
बता सकता तुम लोग मेरे ईवीएम के पीछे
थोड़ी ना खड़े
थे चलिए तो यहां प आपको समझ में आ गया अब
यहां प मेरे को डेटाबेस मिल चुकी है चलिए
डेटाबेस मुझे मिल चुकी है इन डेटाबेस में
एक सिक्योरिटी डेटाबेस भी है अब मैं यहां
प टेबल फाइंड करने की कोशिश करता हूं मैं
य पर क्या करूंगा देखो यहां प यहां पे
यूनियन बेस प जाऊंगा ठीक है यूनियन बस पर
गया टेबल्स पर गया टेबल नेम्स प मैं आ रहा
हूं टेबल नेम्स प जैसे ही मैं आऊंगा ये
डेटाबेस का नाम पूछेगा तो मैं यहां पर
देता हूं सिक्योरिटी एंड यहां पर मैं ओके
करता हूं ओके करने पे मुझे यह कमांड आ गई
अब मैं इस कमांड को यहां प कॉपी करता हूं
एंड अगेन वही काम करूंगा जो काम मैंने
आपको थोड़ी देर पहले बोला था यहां पर
कमांड डाला सॉरी एडिट प गए रिप्लेस प गए
प्लस को स्पेस से रिप्लेस कर दिया एंड वी
गॉट द एक्चुअल कमांड प्लस वाली कमांड यहां
पर गए वन के जगह पर हमने इसको पेस्ट कर
दिया सबमिट किया एंड वी गट द टेबल्स
टेबल्स कौन से ईमेल्स रेफर यूजर एजेंट
यूजर्स एक्सेट एक् राइट समझ में आ गया
अरे बड़ा जल्दी तुम
लोग पॉलिटिक्स के बाद बड़ा जल्दी तुम लोग
एक्साइटेड हो जाते हो पढ़ाई पर ध्यान दे
लो हा यह भी बात है व्ट इफ सर ने नोटा को
वोट किया एकदम सही अनीश क्या ठीक है यार
मैंने नोटा भी दिया कौन ठीक है यार मैंने
हो सकता है मैंने नोटा प बटन दबा दिया हो
हो सकता है मैंने बीजेपी पर दबा दिया हो
सकता हूं मैंने कांग्रेस पर दबा दिया हो
कुछ भी हो सकता है नोबडी नोज ठीक है जिसकी
गवर्नमेंट आएगी
अपन उसके
साइड ठीक है नोटा की आएगी नोटा के साइड है
बीजेपी आए बीजेपी की साइड है कांग्रेस की
आएगी कांग्रेस के साइड है सबको मौका मिलना
चाहिए भाई मैं जब प्रधानमंत्री बनू तो मैं
मेरे साइड रहूंगा और मेरे को वोट जाइए सभी
लोग दीजिएगा ठीक
है
धन्यवाद अरे जबरदस्ती क्या क्या आयुष
जबरदस्ती तुम लोग यार क्या बोल रहे हो
मतलब किसी को भी दे सकता हूं मैं तो सही
बात है हो सकता है कुछ
भी सर कैन ईवीएम बी हैक्ड ईवीएम एक ईवीएम
इलेक्ट्रॉनिक गैजेट्स है जिसके अंदर
प्रोग्रामिंग है किसी तरह की तो ओबवियसली
ट कैन बी मैल फंक्शन दैट कैन बी
मैनिपुलेटेड ब जरूरी नहीं कि होता ही हो
यार क्या तुम लोग भी
चलो ठीक है तो हमारे पास आ गई यह कमांड
हमने यहां पे पेस्ट किया स्पेस वाली और
इसको हमने यहां पे कॉपी कर लिया एंड हमने
यहां पे यहां पे इसको यहां पे हमने पेस्ट
कर दिया फिलहाल अब इसको यहां पे डाल देते
हैं तो चलिए यूनियन ऑल सेलेक्ट वाली कमांड
यहां कॉपी किया यहां पेस्ट किया वन के जगह
प हम यहां पे यह वाली जो हमारी चीज है
इसको हमने यहां प डाल दिया एंड यहां सबमिट
कर दिया सबमिट करते ही हमारे पास ये आ गए
टेबल्स के सारे टेबल्स आ गए भैया अब
टेबल्स के बाद अगेन हमें क्या चाहिए भाई
इसके कॉलम्स चाहिए तो अब हमें कॉलम्स
फाइंड करने हैं तो अगेन हम चलेंगे यूनियन
बेस पे अगेन हम चलेंगे कॉलम्स पे एंड कॉलम
नेम्स कॉलम नेम्स में जाएंगे तो टेबल नेम
पूछ रहा है तो भाई टेबल नेम कौन सा चाहिए
तो मुझे यूजर्स का चाहिए तो चलिए यूजर्स
का दिया चलिए यूजर्स पे आ गए अब हमें अगेन
यहां पे कमांड मिल गई यहां पे हमने कॉपी
किया अगेन अगेन क्या है भाई ये हट जा अगेन
हम यहां पे गए यहां पे गए यह कमांड यहां
पे
डाला अगेन यहां पे एडिट पे गए रिप्लेस पे
गए एंड यहां पर प्लस को स्पेस से रिप्लेस
कर दिया ठीक है अगेन हमने यहां पर इसको
कॉपी कर ली अगेन हम यहां पर गए यहां पर
हमने इसको पेस्ट कर दिया यूनियन ऑल
सेलेक्ट कॉपी किया य हमने डाला वन के जगह
पे हम यहां पे जो कॉलम्स है उसकी वाली
कमांड को यहां पे पुट डाउन कर देंगे एंड
सबमिट करेंगे सबमिट करते ही यहां पे हमारे
को यहां मिल गई आप देख सकते हैं यूजर करंट
कनेक्शंस एक हमें कौन-कौन सी भाई इसके
अंदर में कॉलम्स मिल गई तो आईडी मिल गई
यूजर नेम मिल गया पासवर्ड मिल गया ठीक है
गट इट यूजर नेम पासवर्ड हमें मिल चुका है
यह तो आपको समझ में आ गया होगा यह सबको
समझ में आ
गया यह सबको समझ में आ गया यूजर नेम और
पासवर्ड आ चुकी है यहां
पर ठीक है यह समझ में आ रहा है सबको भाई
इधर देखो यार तुम लोग पॉलिटिक्स में यार
एक बात मतलब एक यार फालतू बात करो तुम लोग
उसमें इतना घुस जाते हो और एक पढ़ाई की
बात करो उसमें कोई आता ही नहीं है यह समझ
में आया पहले य बताओ
जल्दी भाई सच बता रहा हूं गवर्नमेंट किसी
की भी आए ऑन सीरियस
नोट आपके अंदर स्किल होगी टैलेंट होगा ना
तो आपको जॉब लगेगी हां जॉब वैकेंसीज
क्रिएट करना एंड व अपॉर्चुनिटी लाना
गवर्नमेंट के हाथ में है इसलिए गवर्नमेंट
इ वेरी इंपोर्टेंट किसकी आ रही है कैसे आ
रही है बट अपने स्किल्स के दम पर ही आप वो
वैकेंसी को फिल कर सकते हो या जॉब ले सकते
हो तो उसके लिए आप मेहनत करो ठीक है
गवर्नमेंट तो आना जाना लगा रहेगा राइट
चलिए तो यहां पे वी गॉट यहां पे कॉलम्स
हमें मिल गए यूजर नेम पासवर्ड वाले ठीक है
वी गट द यूजरनेम पासवर्ड राइट अब यहां पे
हमें डाटा चाहिए तो हमें डाटा के लिए अगेन
क्या करना है यूनियन
बेस्ट कॉलम में यूजर नेम एंड पासवर्ड दो
कॉलम है डाटा चाहिए डेटा ग्रुप यहां पर कर
देते हैं डेटाबेस कौन सा भैया तो डेटाबेस
हमारा स सिक्योरिटी था ना सिक्योरिटी
टेबल नेम कौन था
यूजर्स ठीक है अब कौन-कौन से कॉलम चाहिए
भैया तो यूजर नेम पासवर्ड यूजर नेम
पासवर्ड दो कॉलम चाहिए यूजर नेम पासवर्ड
यही थाना यूजर नेम एंड पासवर्ड हमने य
किया एंड कर दिया अब हमारे पास यह चीज आ
गई कॉपी किया अगेन ल गो हियर यर यहां पर
हमने पेस्ट कर दिया एंड यहां पर हमने इसको
रिप्लेस कर
दिया प्लस को रिप्लेसिंग प्लस विद
द स्पेस एंड यहां पर रिप्लेस ऑल रिप्लेस
कर दिया यहां पर हमने इसको कॉपी कर लिया
ठीक
है यहां पर चलते हैं अरे भाई यहां पे
क्लास की बातें देखो यार क्लास की बातें
करो यह फालतू बातें मत करो प्लीज आप लोग
ठीक है अब हो गया हो गया जो बातें होनी थी
हो गई अब यहां देखो य हमने प्लस वाली
पेस्ट कर दी अब यहां पर यूनियन ऑल सेलेक्ट
वाली चीज यहां प लाते हैं यहां डालते हैं
वन की जगह पे हमें अब डाटा चाहिए तो हमने
डेटा वाला जो हमारा है फंडा कमांड इसको
पेस्ट किया सबमिट किया सबमिट जैसे ही
करेंगे हमें यहां पे यूजर नेम पासवर्ड मिल
चुका है अब यहां पे सेपरेटर यूज कर लेते
हैं भाई क्या सेपरेटर कैसे यूज करना था
हमें अ टट टट टट टट ऐसे कर दिया भाई ऐसे
ही था ना कॉमा दे दिया ठीक
है नाउ लेट्स
यहां इसको डबल कोट में लाके देखते हैं एंड
यहां पे एग्जीक्यूट करके देखते
हैं ये क्या हो गया भाई हां इसको तो यहां
करना था ना यार यहां
यहां ठीक है वी गट इट यहां से हमने कॉपी
किया यहां हमने पेस्ट किया यहां हमने वन
के जगह पे इसको हमने यहां पे कॉपी किया
यहां पे पेस्ट किया एंड यहां पे वी किया
सबमिट किया सबमिट करते ही हमें यहां प
सेपरेटर का काम हो चुका एंड यहां पे हमें
यूजर नेम पासवर्ड जो है वो मिल चुकी है
डीसीएसपी कोर्स कब लॉन्च होगा जून के एंड
में लॉन्च होगा भैया ठीक है डीसीएसपी
कोर्स के बारे में आपको इंक्वायरी अगर
फॉर्म फिल करके रख देनी है कि क्या आप
ताकि हम आपको कांटेक्ट कर पाएं तो आप
हमारी वेबसाइट पे जाइएगा di.com पे ये
हमारा फोन नंबर है
whatsapp.in में डीसीएसपी का लिस्टेड है
गेट डिटेल्स ऑफ दिस बैच पे आइएगा अपना फोन
फुल नेम ईमेल एड्रेस फोन नंबर एंड यहां
सेलेक्ट कर लीजिएगा डीसीएसपी बैच अपना कुछ
मैसेज होगा तो डाल के सबमिट कर दीजिएगा
आपकी डिटेल्स हमारे पास आ जाएगी हम आपको
जैसे ही लॉन्च होगी कांटेक्ट कर
लेंगे हा ठीक है भैया तो वी गॉट हियर अब
ये था पोस्ट बेस्ड पोस्ट बेस्ड में हमने
ये किया हमने समझ लिया क्या करना था हमें
पोस्ट बेस में सिंपल सा फंडा था हमें क्या
करना था माइनस माइनस प्लस के जगह पे हैश
यूज किया या माइनस माइनस स्पेस यूज किया
प्लस के जगह पे स्पेस यूज करना है एंड
यहां पे हमें याद रखना हमें नेगलिजिबल
नेगेटिव वाली चीज नहीं करनी थी यूनियन ऑल
सिलेक्ट जो हम कर रहे थे पहले ना एरर को
नेगेटिव कर रहे थे वो चीज नहीं करनी थी
सिंपल सा आप यूनियन ल सिलेक्ट ऑर्डर बाय
करके एंड यहां पर आप डटा डेटा बेस जो है
वो फेज कर पाएंगे ठीक है एवरीवन गट इट कुछ
लोगों को देखो जबरदस्ती यार हटने आ जाते
हैं चलो इनको कर देते हैं टाइम आउट
नेक्स्ट 24 घंटे के लिए ठीक है गट
इट सर प्राइस टेंपरिंग वने बिलिटी हो गई
क्या हां जी भैया विशाल सिंह प्राइस
टेंपरिंग लेबिलिटी हुई है कि नहीं बताओ
जरा जल्दी विशाल पूछ रहा है आप लोग लाइन
से नहीं वीडियोस देखते क्लासेस देखते क्या
अनीश सर आपका यह पूरा प्लेलिस्ट स्टार्ट
करने से पहले मुझे कितना फंडामेंटल क्लियर
होना चाहिए या नॉलेज होना चाहिए एक
एसक्यूएल पाइथन लिटिल बिट देखो स्टार्ट
करने से पहले वैसे तो कुछ खास
रिक्वायरमेंट आपकी नहीं है बट हमारे चैनल
पर आपका एसक्यूएल का एक सीरीज है उसको देख
लीजिएगा काले लेस की सीरीज है उसको देख
लीजिएगा ट्स इट मोर
देन ठीक है गट इट अब हम यहां पर आ जाते
हैं अब हम एक दूसरे लेसन पर चलते हैं जो
कि है देखो अब ये लेसन 11 है लेसन 11 के
बाद ये भी पोस्ट बेस सिंगल एरर बेस सिंगल
कोट है पोस्ट बेट ये डबल कोट वाली है अब
लेसन 12 भी वही है सेम चीज है कुछ नहीं है
लेसन 12 में गाइस इफ यू विल गो टू द लेसन
12 ये देखो यहां पे लेसन 12 पे चलते हैं
ये भी सेम पोस्ट एरर बेस डबल कोड्स बेस्ड
है और कुछ भी नहीं है ठीक है तो यहां पे
चलेंगे तो यहां पे अगर मैं स्पेस देके
यहां सबमिट करूं 12 वाली लेसन को तो यहां
पे भी एरर आ रहा है बट यहां पे अब डबल कोट
आ रही है तो भैया ठीक है भैया तो डबल कोट
आ गया फिर माइनस माइनस स्पे
या फिर है से इसको सॉल्व कर लेंगे सबमिट
सॉल्व हो गई अगेन फिर वही वाली कहानी हो
जाएगी कि सेम
चीज सॉरी
सॉरी डबल कोट एंड हैश एंड यहां पर कर
देंगे यूनियन
ऑल
सेलेक्ट यूनियन ऑल सेलेक्ट नटू एंड यहां
पर सबमिट करेंगे हो हो क्या हो रहा है भाई
यूनियन ऑल सिलेक्ट यहां पर सबमिट किया एंड
डबल कोट यहां पे है एंड यहां पे हमने हैश
किया एंड यहां पे वनटू किया लॉगिन फेल्ड आ
रहा है क्यों आ रहा है भाई लॉगइन फेल्ड
बताओ जल्दी बताओ जल्दी बताओ जल्दी बताओ
जल्दी जल्दी जल्दी
जल्दी जल्दी बताइए गाइस नटू किया क्या एरर
आ रही है लैब नंबर लेसन नंबर
12 बताइए
जल्दी क्यों रर आ रही
है जल्दी गाइस जल्दी गाइस जल्दी गाइस
थोड़ा फास्ट बताइए तो
बताइए सम शो नहीं करता लॉगिन फेल अटेंट आ
रहा है
ना लॉगिन फेल्ड अटेंप्ट आ रहा है भाई
लॉगइन फे अटम आ रहा
बताओ यूनियन ल सेलेक्ट
किया किसी को पता है कुछ कोड एरर क्या कोड
एरर
चलो ऑर्डर
बाय हा चलिए यहां पे हमने जब यह किया था
सबमिट किया था तो यहां पे आपको दिख रहा
होगा कि यहां पे डबल कोट एंड ब्रैकेट ये आ
रही थी आपके एरर में बिल्कुल डबल कोट
ब्रैकेट तो इसको सॉल्व करने के लिए डबल
कोट ब्रैकेट लगा के तब हम हैश यूज करेंगे
एंड देन वी विल सबमिट इट एंड इट विल गेट
सॉल्वड अब हम यहां पे यूनियन ऑल सेलेक्ट 1
2 लगाएंगे एंड अब हम सबमिट करेंगे तो हमें
यहां पे कॉलम्स मिल गए एंड जब कॉलम्स मिल
गए तो आपको पता है कि आगे आपको क्या करना
है यू ऑलरेडी नो लाइक आगे क्या होना चाहिए
ठीक है ये आपको तो समझ में आ ही गया होगा
चलिए मैं यहां पर एक क्लास है मैं उसको
स्टार्ट कर देता हूं जस्ट वेट गाइस थोड़ा
वेट कर लीजिए थोड़ा वेट कीजिए ओके ओके ओके
ओके एक चीज है एक क्लासेस है उसकी मैं
स्टार्टिंग कर देता हूं
गा जस्ट वेट एक सेकंड
यह दूसरी एक बैच है जो हमारी चलती है अभी
डीसी जेएसपी की सो वी हैव हैव टू स्टार्ट
इट अभी टाइम तो है 4 मिनट है 8 बजे से
स्टार्ट होती है
वो उस टाइम में कर देंगे ठीक है चलिए तो
यह तो हमारा हो गया लेसन 12 अब आप लोग तो
आराम से लेसन 12 13 14 यह सब बना लेंगे
ठीक है अब आते हैं लेसन 15 पे अब लेसन 15
का इसलिए है क्योंकि इसमें भी कुछ
कांसेप्ट है जो आपको समझना है यह भी मैं
आपको समझाऊ पहले लेसन 15 क्या है पोस्ट
ब्लाइंड बुलियन और टाइम बेस्ड सिंगल कोर्स
ये थोड़ा डिफरेंट यहां पर लेसन 15 है आपका
लेसन 15 प आते हैं याद रखिएगा एसक्यूएल
इंजेक्शन के थर्ड पार्ट में हम फुल
ऑटोमेशन पे जाएंगे यानी फुल ऑटोमेटेड वे
हम उस क्लास को करेंगे यानी कि हम टूल्स
का यूज करने वाले हैं अलग-अलग डिफरेंट
डिफरेंट चीजें हम देखने वाले हैं
क्या-क्या चीजें होती है बायपास देखने
वाले हैं कैसे फायरवॉल बायपासेस वगैरह जो
है वो आप कर सकते हैं या काम करते हैं ये
सारी चीज हम देखने वाले हैं क्लास पार्ट
नंबर थ्री में एसकल इंजेक्शन के तो पार्ट
नंबर थ्री जो होगा यानी कि क्लास नंबर 35
जो होगा नेक्स्ट क्लास उसको जरूर देखिएगा
बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट होगा या ध्यान रखिएगा
एसक्यूएल मैप के ऊपर होगा और कुछ टूल्स है
और कुछ यूटिलिटीज है उसके ऊपर होगा और
आपको फायरल बायपास डिफरेंट डिफरेंट ऑफ
डेटा पैकेट्स और डेटा लेंथ और इन सब चीजों
के बारे में पता चलेगा फ्रेगमेंटेशन के
बारे में थोड़ा सा आपको बताया जाएगा तो हर
एक चीज आपको पता चलेगी उसमें तो जरूर
देखिएगा ठीक
है चलिए लेसन 15 प आ जाते हैं लोड यूआरएल
कर लेते हैं इसको थोड़ा सा जूम इन कर लेते
हैं लेसन 15 में जब हम यहां पे फॉरवर्ड
स्लैश करके एंड इसमें एरर सॉल्व करने की
कोशिश करेंगे तो यहां एरर कुछ भी नहीं आ
रहा मतलब एरर लाने की कोशिश करते हैं ना
तो एरर तो कुछ भी नहीं आ
रहा ठीक है वेलकम
आयुष ठीक है एरर कुछ भी नहीं आ रहा अब
क्या
करेंगे अब क्या करेंगे
एरर कुछ भी नहीं आ रहा तो एरर कुछ भी नहीं
आ रहा इसका मतलब है यहां
पे इसका मतलब
है कि ये
आपको कुछ एरर सामने दिख नहीं रहा
है आपको सामने दिख नहीं रहा यह एरर अब यह
दिख नहीं रहा इसलिए इस लैब का नाम
है ब्लाइंड बुलियन ब्लाइंड बुलियन या टाइम
मैंने आपको बताया था ब्लाइंड में बुलियन
या टाइम बस्ड होगा अब आपको बुलियन का मतलब
थोड़ा समझाता हूं बुलियन का मतलब क्या
होता है पहले वो समझाता हूं लेट्स
अंडरस्टैंड द बुलियन का मतलब बुलियन का
मतलब क्या हो जाता
है इन इवेंट इन एन
इवेंट आउट ऑफ टू
रेंस ओनली ओनली वन इज पॉसिबल
यह होता है बुलियन का मतलब इवेंट आउट ऑफ
टू करेंस ओनली वन इ पॉसिबल जब आप टॉस करते
हो कॉइन को नवर यू टॉस कॉइन क्या होता है
या तो हेड आएगा या टेल आएगा हेड टेल दोनों
तो नहीं आ जाएगा ना होता है क्या कभी आपके
साथ कभी ऐसा हुआ है कि हेड एंड टेल दोनों
आगे हो जब कॉइन को ट टॉस करते हो
तो बता दीजिए एक सेकंड गाइस बताइए जल्दी
बताइए कभी ऐसा हुआ है दोनों आ गए हो
[संगीत]
मैं राइट राइट राइट ओके लेट मी स्टार्ट अ
सेशन एक क्लास है उसको मैं स्टार्ट कर
देता हूं जल्दी से
अ ओके
ओके
ओके ओके मैम मैंने आपको होस्ट बना दिया है
तो आप प्लीज हैंडल इट बिकॉज अभी मैं एक
लाइव सेशन में
हूं ओके
ओके तो चलिए यह तो हमारी क्लास स्टार्ट हो
गई
है चलिए तो हमारी एक लाइव क्लास थी राइट
तो उसको स्टार्ट कर रहा था मैं 8 पीएम से
होती है ओके ओके इनन इवेंट आउट ऑफ टू
करेंस ओनली वन इज पॉसिबल ठीक है हेड आया
मतलब एक कॉइन टच किया तो हेड आया या टू या
टेल आएगा ठीक है वैसे ही बाइनरी डिजिट के
फॉर्म में बाइनरी डिजिट्स के फॉर्म में
बुलियन के अंदर बाइनरी डिजिट के फॉर्म में
क्या होता है ज़ीरो एंड वन होता है जहां
पे ज़ीरो का मतलब हो जाता है फॉल्स एंड वन
का मतलब हो जाता है
ट्रू इससे भी हम पता लगा सकते हैं कि
समथिंग इज हैपनिंग ऑर नॉट या समथिंग इज
हैपनिंग र नॉट और समथिंग इज ट्रू और फाल्स
यह हम पता लगा सकते हैं दिस वी कैन फाइंड
थ्रू द बुलियन मेथड और इसका यूज़ हम एल
इंजेक्शन में करते हैं ठीक है चलिए अब
इसका मतलब मैं समझाता हूं अब जैसे मान लो
लेटस सपोज लेसन 15 है लॉगइन अटेम्प्ट य
फेल्ड आ रहा है लेसन 15 मैं य पर क्या
करता हूं एडमिन एडमिन करता हूं य प एंड य
पर सबमिट करता हूं सक्सेसफुली लक क्यों
क्योंकि एडमिन एंड एडमिन ट्रू हो चुका है
इस केस में अब यहां पर ना इसमें क्या करते
हैं हम कैसे चेक करते हैं अब मैं मान के
चलो मैं फॉरवर्ड स्ल देता हूं सबमिट करता
हूं फेल्ड आ रहा है मैं सिंगल कोड देता
हूं
सबमिट करता हूं लॉगइन फेल्ड आ रहा है मैं
डबल कोड देता हूं सबमिट करता हूं चेक कर
रहा हूं मैं कि ये वल्नरेबल है कि नहीं
कुछ नहीं फेल्ड आ रहा है मैं क्या करता
हूं फॉरवर्ड स्ल सिंगल कोट ब्रैकेट देता
हूं सॉरी सिंगल कोट ब्रैकेट देता हूं यहां
पे सबमिट करता हूं फेल्ड आ रहा है मैं
यहां पर सिंगल डबल कोट ब्रैकेट देता हूं
यहां पे सबमिट करता हूं फेल्ड आ रहा है
कैसे भी हम चेक नहीं कर पा
रहे बहुत इनफ है भाई बहुत इनफ है वेरी मच
इनफ ठीक है फेल आ रहा अब इसको हम कैसे
टेस्ट करेंगे यह मैं आपको को सिखाता हूं
इसके लिए हम अलग टाइप का एक पेलोड जनरेट
करेंगे किस टाइप का
पेलोड बुलियन
पेलोड हम एक ब बुलियन पेलोड जनरेट करेंगे
अब ये बुलियन पेलोड भाई क्या होता है पहले
वो आप समझिए देखिए सबसे पहले हम एक सिंगल
कोट एरर पेलोड जनरेट करेंगे सिंगल कोट एरर
पेलोड प चेक करेंगे कैसे एक सिंगल कोट
सिंगल कोट और
और और हम किसी तरह का कंपैरिजन कर लेंगे
किसी भी तरह का जैसे न
इव सिंगल कोट और न इव और स्पेस के बाद हैश
दे देंगे क्योंकि पोस्ट बेस्ड है तो है
उसको
लाइक क्या करने के लिए आपको पता ही है ठीक
है सॉल्व करने के अब यहां का मतलब क्या
हुआ आप समझिए सिंगल कोट हम सिंगल कोट
क्यों दे रहे हैं आप जब आएंगे लेसन प 15
में तो आपको यहां पर दिख रहा होगा पोस्ट
ब्लाइंड बुलियन टाइम बेस सिंगल कोट तो
हमने सिंगल कोट से चेक किया पहले सिंगल
कोट पर चेकिंग कर रहे हैं बढ़िया बात है
और कंपैरिजन कर रहे या तो सिंगल कोट हो या
न इव दोनों में से जो ट्रू
हो मुझे
बताओ आप चेक कर रहे हो अब इसको हम ऐसे भी
चेक कर सकते हैं डबल कोट
और 1 इव श हम इसको ऐसे भी चेक कर देते हैं
सिंगल सॉरी सिंगल कोट ब्रैकेट
और सॉरी इव श ऐसे भी चेक कर सकते हैं या
डबल कोट ब्रैकेट और व इ
टू न हैश ऐसे भी कर सकते हैं तो यह एक तरह
का पेलोड बन गया ना हमारा वी डेवलप पेलो
काइंड ऑफ
पेलो ऐसे ही नर्मल जो कांसेप्ट है वही है
हम इसमें बुलियन वाला कांसेप्ट एक घुसा
रहे हैं बुलियन में हम कंपैरिजन करते हैं
कोई चीज ट्रू है या फाल्स है राइट है या
रंग है मतलब है एक्चुअली में कौन सा चीज
हो रहा है टॉस किया तो हेड आया कि टेल आया
ट्स व्हाट वी आर कंपेयरिंग हियर समझ में आ
रहा है आप लोगों को बुलियन का कांसेप्ट
बुलियन में हम क्या कर देते हैं अगर आप
ऐसे भी करोगे
लाइक ग भी करोगे
ना बुलियन मीनिंग ऐसे गल भी कर लेते हैं
तो यहां पर देख सकते हो इन कंप्यूटिंग
टर्म बुलियन मींस द रिजल्ट कैन ओनली हैव
वन ऑफ द टू पॉसिबल वैल्यूज ट्रू और फाल्स
बस यही है समझ में आ रहा आर यू गेटिंग
गाइस प्लीज जल्दी बता दीजिए प्लीज जल्दी
बताइए रिप्लाई किया रिप्लाई
करो यह समझ में आ रहा
है
सॉरी एवरीवन गेटिंग
इ है पा ठीक है तो बस वही काम यहां पर हो
रहा है तो हमने एक पलट बना लिया अब चलो हम
पलट को टेस्ट करते हैं पलट पलट जो है हम
इसको टेस्ट करेंगे कैसे टेस्ट करेंगे भाई
तो यहां पर है यहां पर हम सीधा क्या
करेंगे पहले हम क्या करते मान लो हम यह
पेलो टेस्ट करते हैं डबल कोट वाली यह पेलो
टेस्ट करते हैं तो हम यहां पर जाते हैं
यूजर नेम में डालते हैं ए य पर सबमिट करते
हैं अगेन लॉगिन फेल्ड ही आ रहा है लॉगिन
फेल्ड ही आ रहा है
लॉगइन फेडली आ रहा है सर आई वांटेड सजेशन
वेदर योर एथिकल हैकिंग कोर्स इज इनफ और आई
हैव टू टेक मोर क्लासेस लेते रहो क्लासे
जो कोर्स है डीसी जेएसपी वाली वो तो अपने
आप में बहुत ही शानदार है लर्निंग की कोई
लिमिट नहीं है अगर लन सीखना चाहते हो
सीखते जाओ बहुत सारी चीजें हैं और इस
सीरीज को तो पूरी फॉलो करो बक बाउंट वाली
सीरीज को ठीक है चलो अब हम यहां पे ये
वाली पेलोड ट्राई करते हैं लेट्स ट्राई
दिस पेलोड सिंगल कोट वाली य हमने डाला एंड
यहां पे सबमिट करते हैं जैसे ही सबमिट
किया सक्सेसफुली लॉक्ड इन एज सून वी
सबमिटेड सक्सेसफुली लॉक्ड
इन ये होती है आपकी बुलियन
बेस्ड ब्लाइंड बुलियन दिख नहीं रहा था एरर
फिर भी स्कल इंजेक्शन था ये हमने चेक किया
ट्रू और फाल्स से वी चेक्ड फ्रॉम ट्रू एंड
फॉल्स उसी तरीके से टाइम बेस में ना हम
स्लिप फंक्शन लगा के टेस्ट करते हैं और
कुछ नहीं होता तो हमने वो ट्रू फॉल्स से
चेक कर लिया
अब देखो इसको कैसे इसको थोड़ा तरीका इसका
बता देता हूं मैं यहां पे अब मान लो हमने
चेक तो कर लिया यहां पे अब ये कैसे काम कर
रहा है देखो यह ऐसे ही काम कर रहा है ऐसे
ही काम कर रहा है जैसे देखो तुम्हें अच्छा
तुम लोगों को चलो इसको लाइव दिखाता हूं
मैं लाइव करके तुम लोगों को कोई एक
डेटाबेस का नाम याद है जो हम पहले कर रहे
थे इसी का लैब का एक इस लैब पे सॉरी
डेटाबेस जो बहुत सारे डेटाबेस थे ना उसमें
से कोई एक डेटाबेस का नाम याद है तो
ज्यादा शायद क्लियर में समझा पाऊ डेटाबेस
का नाम याद है आप लोगों
को सिक्योरिटी सिक्योरिटी डेटाबेस था चलो
ठीक है अब इसको उसी फॉर्म में समझते
हैं यह क्यों सक्सेसफुली लगड इन हुआ कैसे
हुआ यह समझते हैं अब देखो सिंगल कोट और 1
इव सिंगल कोड प था लॉगइन हो गया अब मैं
यहां प ना वन के जगह प डेटा बेस डाल देता
हूं फंक्शन डेटाबेस डेटाबेस इ इक्वल टू
मैं नाम दे देता हूं कुछ भी डि फ्रक्स
इसको डबल कोट में ही डालेंगे स्ट्रिंग की
तरह तभी यह वर्क करेगा ट्रॉनिक्स मैंने
डाल
दिया अब डेटाबेस डि फोनिक्स तो नहीं
है डेटाबेस सर नमाज का टाइम हो रहा है मैं
जा रहा हूं थोड़ी देर बाद हां बिल्कुल
बिल्कुल कासिम बिल्कुल कासम बिल्कुल जाओ
ठीक है कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है यहां डि
फोनिक्स है क्या डेटाबेस का नाम था क्या
डेटाबेस का नाम मतलब मान लो लेट्स सपोज
हमें डेटाबेस का नाम पता है जस्ट फॉर
टेस्टिंग मैं आपको समझाने के लिए कर रहा
हूं और कुछ नहीं है ठीक है वैसे तो हमें
डेटाबेस का नाम नहीं पता पता होगा ना
लेकिन बस टेस्टिंग के लिए मैं आपको समझा
रहा हूं बस और कुछ नहीं नहीं है सबमिट
करता हूं ये देखो लॉगइन अटेम्प्ट फेल्ड
लॉगिन अटेंप्ट फेल्ड इसने डेटाबेस में
जाके क्वेरी करी इस कमांड ने क्या
किया इस कमांड ने डेटाबेस
यहां पे किया मैंने एंड यहां पे मैंने
डाला डि
फ्रक्स अब इस कमांड ने बेसिकली करा
क्या इस कमांड ने डेटा यह कमांड डेटाबेस
के अंदर गया और यहां पर कंपेयर किया
क्योंकि हम बुलियन के थ्रू कर रहे हैं
कंपेयर किया कि भैया डेटाबेस कोई डिक्स है
क्या तो नहीं है तो यहां पर क्या आ रहा है
लॉगिन एटम फेल्ड अब अगर सेम जगह डि
फोनिक्स के जगह पर हम यहां पर सिक्योरिटी
डाल दे जो एक्चुअली एजिस्ट करती है जो
हमें पता है कि है और फिर सबमिट करें देन
देखो सक्सेसफुली लगड इन हो गए
देखा देन वी गट लगड इन य दे कि नहीं देखा
पहले य बताओ
यार देखा ये
सबने बिल्कुल बिल्कुल अफगान गेमिंग आप
जाइए ओके गट इट एवरी बडी बढ़िया था ना इजी
था
या बेस्ट टूल एल मैप एस
बेस्ट मैप बेस्ट
बेस्ट ठीक है तो यहां पर हमें क्या मिला
भैया हमें यहां पर मिल गई बेसिकली जो ट्रू
फल्स था हमें पता चल गया कि हा भैया यह
काम कर रहा है यह वाली हमारी जो जो चीज है
यह वाली जो हमारी पेलोड है यह यहां पर
काम कर रही है
और यहां पर काम कर रहा है बिल्कुल एब्सलूट
इट्स
वर्किंग इटस
वर्किंग ठीक है अब यहां पे हम क्या करते
हैं व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू डू यहां पर व्ट
वी आर गोइंग टू डू हमें मान लो डेटाबेस
चाहिए यहां तो हमने कंपेरिजन कर लिया और व
इव ऐसे करके कंपेयर कर दिया अब हम मान लो
और श
और सिंगल कोड और और यहां पर अगर हम डेटा
बेस लिख दे और यहां पर इस तरीके से कर दे
और यहां पर सबमिट करें तो यहां पर क्या आ
रहा है
फेल्ड तो बेसिकली इस केस
में हम क्या
करेंगे इस केस में हम डेटाबेस का नाम कैसे
फाइंड करेंगे बताओ जरा कोई देखा
कैसे फाइंड करेंगे डेटाबेस का
नाम पहले यह स्पैम वाले लोग को थोड़ा
निकालना पड़ेगा यार दूसरा कुछ नहीं कर
सकते बताओ कैसे फाइंड करेंगे य पर इस केस
में हाउ वी विल गेट द डेटाबेस
ने बहुत अच्छी बात
है क्या बात है कांग्रेचुलेशन
जकास गेमर मतलब कांग्रेचुलेशन विकास मोरे
ऑन योर फाइंडिंग
ग्रेट
अरे यहां पे मैं क्या बोल रहा हूं यहां पे
हमारे पर्टिकुलर इस वाले चीज पे यहां पे
कहां पे हम क्या चीज डालेंगे
बताइए मुझे जल्दी बताइए जल्दी जल्दी
टटर थ जल्दी बताइए फास्ट फास्ट गाइ हरी अप
हरी अप गा हरी अप हरी अप गाइस प्लीज हरी
अप हरी अप हरी अप हरी अप हरी अप हरी
अप जल्दी बताइए गाइस आई एम वेटिंग मैं चैट
देख रहा हूं गाइस आप लोग यार सही टाइम पर
तो रिप्लाई नहीं करते हो यार समझ नहीं आता
कि मुझे कुछ सही में यार समझ नहीं आता कि
आप लोग सही टाइम प रिप्लाई करते क्यों
नहीं हो मैं यहां पर चैट देख रहा
हूं और डेटाबेस इ इक्वल टू
अरे तो ये तो तुमने कंपेरिजन कर दी ना
तुमने तो कंपैरिजन कर
दी तुमने तो कंपैरिजन कर दी ना भाई
देखो एक्चुअली में इस केस में ना देखो
एक्चुअली में इस केस में आपको गेस करना
पड़ता है लेटर्स वाइज लेटर्स की तरह आपको
गेस करना है लेटर्स वाइज आपको गेस करना है
आपको क्या करना है गेस करना है जैसे आपने
डेटाबेस वहां पर डेटाबेस वाली कमांड यहां
पर डाली हुई थी ना जैसे कि मैं क्या कर
देता हू यहां पे डेटाबेस वाली कौन सी
कमांड थी
हमारी यह वाली हमने यहां पर यह चीज डाली
थी यह वाली चीज यहां पर हमने सिक्योरिटी
यहां पर सिक्योरिटी का हमने डाला हुआ था
राइट हमें अगर हमें ये चीज नहीं पता मान
लो हमें तो सिक्योरिटी का हमें पता ही
नहीं है ना हमें वी डोंट नो अबाउट
सिक्योरिटी हमें तो कुछ आईडिया नहीं है तो
अब यहां पर हम कैसे करेंगे तो हम यहां पर
गेसिंग करते हैं एंड गेस करके ही फिर आपको
पता चलेगा कि कौन सा लेटर है भैया उस
डेटाबेस का पहला लेटर कौन सा है दूसरा
लेटर इस तरीके से ठीक है और डेटाबेस
[संगीत]
अच्छा
चलिए ठीक है मैं इसका भी एक बार आपको यस
जो बोल रहा है व भी करके दिखा देता हूं
हां जी हां जी थोड़ा सा ट्रिकी है
प्रैक्टिस करना पड़ेगा बिना प्रैक्टिस का
नहीं होगा बिना प्रैक्टिस का नहीं होगा
क्या बात है क्या बात है गौरव कुमार पहले
से सॉल्व कर लिया पहले से सॉल्व कर लिया
क्या पहले से सॉल्व कर लिया क्या गौरव
गौरव
कुमार सब स्ट्रिंग कहां से ला दी सब
स्ट्रिंग कहां से ला
दी बताओ बताओ सब स्ट्रिंग कहां से ला दी
सब स्ट्रिंग का मतलब बताओ देखो यहां पर आप
को थोड़ा सा गेसिंग करना पड़ेगा गेसिंग
करने के लिए यहां पे एक यूटिलिटी है सब
स्ट्रिंग सब स्ट्रिंग इसको यूज करना पड़ता
है बिना इसके आप वो चीज नहीं कर सकते यानी
कि सब स्ट्रिंग आप गेस कर रहे हैं बेसिकली
एक पर्टिकुलर डेटाबेस के अंदर में और किस
चीज के लिए एक वेरिएबल के लिए जो हम अभी
डिफाइन
करेंगे इस एक वेरिएबल के लिए जो आप डिफाइन
करेंगे तो यहां पे सिंगल कोट और लगाया
आपने एंड आपने सब स्ट्रिंग लगा लिया एंड
सब स्ट्रिंग किस चीज की भैया डेटाबेस
डेटाबेस डेटाबेस क्योंकि फंक्शन है तो
हमने फंक्शन भी यहां पर इसको बना दिया
डेटाबेस हमने फंक्शन कर दिया अब इसके बाद
हमने यहां पर डाला वन
कॉमा ठीक है वन हमने वनमा वन दे दिया मतलब
इन द सेंस की हम भाई उस उतने उस प्लेस के
लिए वो कर रहे हैं फाइंड हम करने की कोशिश
कर रहे हैं तो हमने यह कर दिया एंड इसको
हमने क्लोज कर दिया क्लोज करने के बाद
यहां
पे सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी इसको रिमूव करते क्लोज
करने बाद यहां पे हम इक्वल्स टू एक
वेरिएबल दे देते हैं जैसे x हमने क्या
किया भैया एक वेरिएबल दे दिया य ये थोड़ा
आप लोग ध्यान दीजिएगा हमने क्या किया एक
वेरिएबल दे दिया x क्योंकि ये स्ट्रिंग है
तो हमने इसको स्ट्रिंग में यहां पे डिफाइन
कर दिया कुछ इस तरीके से एंड यहां पे हमने
इसको कॉपी करके इसको एज अ कमांड में यहां
पे लिख देता
हूं कुछ इस तरीके का
और सिंगल कोट और सब स्ट्रिंग यहां पे देन
डेटाबेस हमने कर दिया एंड उसके बाद हमने
डेटाबेस के अंदर में वन वन ये एक लेटर
दिया एंड यहां पे गेस करने के लिए हमने
इसको एक वेरिएबल का वो कर दिया वेरिएबल
एक्स के एक् यहां पर हमने डिफाइन किया एंड
यहां पे वेरिएबल एक्स डिफाइन करने के बाद
हम यहां पे एक सबमिट करते हैं सबमिट
करेंगे लॉगिन फेल्ड अटेंप्ट फेल्ड आ रहा
है अब हम क्या करेंगे यहां
पे कॉपी किया पेस्ट किया एंड यहां एक्स के
जगह प ए लाते हैं ए एंड यहां पे सबमिट
किया जैसे ही हमने ए लाया हमें आ रहा है
सक्सेसफुली
लगड इसका मतलब क्या हुआ यहां पर हमने एस
लिया ना सेम चीज को यहां पर हमने जैसे ही
एस किया यहां पर यह फॉल्स आ रहा
है यहां पर ये ट्रू आ रहा है ऐसा क्यों आ
रहा
है सर लगता है मेंबरशिप अलाउ करेंगे तब
आएगा सही बात है अब यहां प फल्स आ रहा य
ट्रू आ रहा है क्यों क्योंकि यहां एस जो
है वो डेटाबेस का नाम था ना सिक्योरिटी तो
ये एजिस्ट करता है इसलिए ट्रू आ गया लगड
इन
लेकिन क्योंकि एक्स नाम का कुछ डाटा ही
बेस नहीं था तो यहां फाल्स आ गया अब इस ए
के जगह पर अगर मैं एक्स के जगह देखो एक्स
प तो यह फॉल्स आ रहा है फेल्ड अटेंप्ट अब
यहां प ना य भी डाल दू ना सॉरी टी टेस्ट
यूजर था टेस्ट शायद था हमारा डेटाबेस
टेस्ट था क्या सबमिट करके देख लेते हैं
नहीं था नहीं था नहीं था डेटाबेस एक और था
इंफॉर्मेशन स्कीमा तो आई डाल देते हैं
सबमिट करते हैं नहीं थाा ये नहीं था
क्या सिक्योरिटी था और कुछ था या डेटाबेस
में मुझे याद नहीं आ
रहा चलो एस करके देखते हैं सबमिट या
सक्सेसफुली चलो एस पे आ रहा है डेटाबेस का
नाम था जो भी था तो यहां पे हमारा एस जो
डेटाबेस था वो हमने यहां पे सबमिट किया
एंड वी गट द सक्सेसफुली लगड इन अटेम्प्ट
तो ये आपको गेसिंग करना पड़ता है इस केस
में गेस करोगे एंड फिर आप यहां पे फाइंड
करोगे तो ये गेसिंग टेक्निक हो गई अब ये
चीज ना तुमको पता है कहां पे हेल्प आएगी
तुमने तुम लोगों में एल मैप कितने लोगों
ने यूज किया है अभी तक बताओ मुझे जस्ट लेट
मी नो कितने लोगों ने एसल मैप यूज किया
है जल्दी बता दीजिए जल्दी बता दीजिए कितने
लोगों ने यूज किया है गौरव कुमार ने यूज
किया है आकाश मिश्रा नेयू कि आयुष गुप्ता
निर्ग
राहुल ठीक है एसल मैप में जब आप चलाते हो
ना एल मैप को तो जब बहुत सारे वो तरीको को
यूज कर ले है डेटाबेस फाइंड करने का तो
आपने कई बार देखा होगा ना कुछ टाइम के बाद
वो बुलियन बेस्ड डेटाबेस बुलियन बेस जो है
ना बुलियन बेस्ड वो ट्राई करता है कुछ इस
तरीके का और उसमें वो बुलियन बेस्ड जब
ट्राई करेगा तो आप देखोगे डेटाबेस का नाम
फाइंड नहीं कर पाएगा तो वह लेटर्स
को राउंड अप करता
है लेटर्स को घुमाता है और वह ए बी सी डी
ए जी एच ऐसे ऐसे लिखा हुआ आता है और एक एक
लेटर फाइंड करता है यह लेटर है क्या यह
लेटर है क्या यह लेटर है क्या तब जाके
आपको डेटाबेस देता है तो यह वही कांसेप्ट
है यह जो आपको 15 लैब में जो मैंने आपको
अभी बताया 15 लैब में ब्लाइंड बुलियन यह
वही सेम कांसेप्ट
है यह वही कांसेप्ट
यह समझ में आया यह जब हम एल मैप प देखेंगे
ना एक बार जब आएगा तो आपको क्लियर आउट
होगा य आपको क्लियर आउट होगा ठीक
है सेम चीज और सेम चीज हम जब यह हमने किसम
देखा यह हमने बुलियन बुलियन में देखा टाइम
सॉरी ब्लाइंड में हमने ये चीज किसम देखा
ब्लाइंड बुलियन ब्लाइंड में देखा अब हम
टाइम बस्ट की बात कर रहे ना टाइम बेस्ड की
तो सेम चीज करना टाइम बेस्ड अगर हम एसकल
आई की बात करें तो कुछ नहीं है यहां पर
टाइम बेस में कुछ नहीं है यहां पर आपको
स्लिप यूज करना है बस सिंगल कोट यहां दिया
सिंगल कोट यहां पर दे
देंगे य आप लोग चैट में यार गा ट व्ट यू
आर यू आर डूइंग इन चैट मुझे समझ नहीं आ
रहा चैट में आप लोग क्या बातें करते हो
यार य ग्रुप्स की और यह इधर ध्यान ही नहीं
रहता आपका आप लोग थोड़ा ध्यान ध्यान तो दे
दिया
करो ध्यान तो दिया करो
यार वही तो
यार चैट ऑफ करना ही पड़ेगा मुझे लग रहा है
टाइम बेस में यहां पे क्या होगा यहां पे
सिंगल कोट और एंड यहां पे एक फंक्शन यूज
करेंगे स्लिप मान लो स्लिप दे दिया हमने 5
सेकंड के लिए एंड यहां पे हैश अगर अगर
आपका वेब एप्लीकेशन 5 सेकंड के लिए होल्ड
प चला गया तो वहां पे आपका क्या है टाइम
बेस्ड एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन है सिंपल सा फंड
है तो यही फंडे थे यही सिंपल
लाइक सिंपल सा कांसेप्ट था एसक्यूएल
इंजेक्शन का एसक्यूएल आई का मैनुअल अप्रोच
में जो आपको समझना था मनुअल अप्रोच में बस
और कुछ भी
नहीं ठीक है और कुछ भी नहीं आपसे एक
रिक्वेस्ट है आप सबसे एक रिक्वेस्ट है मैं
आपको बता देता हूं एक रिक्वेस्ट आपसे मैं
आपसे मैं करता हूं यहां पर जो लोग
रिक्वेस्ट को फॉलो कीजिएगा आपके लिए
बेनिफिशियल होगा वो कि आप लोग इस एसकल लैब
को य देखिए एसकल लब को ये आप इंक्रीज करते
जाओ नंबर्स को नंबर्स को इंक्रीज करोगे
नंबर्स को इंक्रीज कर सकते हो नटू जो है
ना वो इंक्रीज कर सकते हो सेकंड के लिए
ठीक है जैसे कि मैं आपको बता देता हूं
जैसे कि यहां पे ये था ना हमारा तो हमारा
कहां गया यह वाली हमने यूज की
थी s के लिए सबमिट किया लॉगइन हो
गया अब यहां पे s के बाद ई आता है ना ई
मैंने ई के लिए किया यहां पे सबमिट किया
कुछ नहीं हो रहा अब मैं क्या करूंगा यहां
पे वन को एक बार टू कर देता हूं एंड देन
सबमिट करता हूं सक्सेसफुली लॉग इन यानी कि
हमारा
जो यहां पे वन को इंक्रीज करना है आपको वन
को टू कर देना है यानी कि सेकंड लेटर के
लिए सेकंड डिजिट के लिए समझ में आ रहा है
आपको वन को टू कर दीजिएगा तो अब s के बाद
e आ गया तो s के बाद ई था तो हमारा यहां
पे सबमिट करने पे सक्सेसफुल लॉगिन आ रहा
है लेकिन अगर आप एस ई के बाद फिर एस लिख
देते हैं सेकंड डिजिट के लिए सबमिट करेंगे
तो यहां प फेल्ड आ रहा है क्योंकि सेकंड
डिजिट एस थो सेकंड एस के बाद ई था
सिक्योरिटी सिक्योरिटी का ई तो यहां प ई
आया और यहां पर वन को टू किया तो यहां पे
व सेकंड डिजिट को खोजे समझ में आ
गया यह क्वेश्चन किसी का था
अभी हाउ टू फाइंड द सेकंड लेटर गौरव गट इट
गौरव समझ में
आया ठीक है बस उसको इंक्रीज करेंगे ये वन
वन जो चीज है लिमिट लिमिट लिमिट है ये ये
लिमिट लगाइए ये लिमिट है बस जैसे मतलब
इसके पूछने का ये था कि सर हम इससे तो
पहला लेटर ए फाइंड कर लिया दूसरा लेटर
हमें फाइंड करना है तो क्या करेंगे तो भाई
कुछ नहीं करेंगे सेम चीज रहेगी इस लिमिट
वन को हम टू करेंगे और दूसरा डिजिट हम चेक
करेंगे ए के बाद ई तो ई अगर ट्रू है तो
ट्रू है फाल्स है फल्स ठीक है हां
इंट्रूडर का यूज कर सकते हो बिल्कुल कर
सकते हो बस सक बिल्कुल बिल्कुल कर सकते हो
इंट्रूडर का यूज कर सकते हो बकुल सेम आपको
डाल के वो करना है बिल्कुल कर सकते हो कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं ठीक है गट इट आप सबको एक
टास्क देता हूं मैं एक टास्क एक टास्क
देता हूं आप सबको टास्क यह है कि आप सबको
एसक्यूएल आई लैब्स जो है जो कि बाय ऑडी
इनका है ये गेट प आपको यहां पर मिल जाएगा
ए लब्स बाय ऑ व इसको सेट अप कर लीजिएगा
अगर नहीं किया आपने तो एंड इसके लैब्स जो
है लेसन जो है वन से लेकर टोटल 22 या 21
तक सारे लेसंस को आप सॉल्व कीजिएगा सारे
लेसंस को और उसके बाद आफ्टर दिस आपको वेब
सिक्योरिटी एकेडमी इन पे जाना है यह भी
बहुत शानदार एक प्लेटफॉर्म है यहां
टॉपिक्स में जाइएगा एंड यहां पे व्यू ऑल
टॉपिक्स पे क्लिक कीजिएगा सर्वर साइड
टॉपिक्स में एएल इंजेक्शन आ जाएगा इस पे
चले जाइएगा एंड यहां पे व्यू ऑल एसक्यूएल
इंजेक्शन लैब पहले एसएल इंजेक्शन के
कांसेप्ट को पढ़ लीजिएगा यहां से और फिर
इसके ला जितने भी लैब्स है ना सारे लैब्स
सॉल्व कर लीजिएगा आपका कांसेप्ट और भी
ज्यादा रिफाइंड हो जाएगा बेसिक मैंने आपको
इतना कांसेप्ट जरूर समझा दिया है कि आपका
दिमाग अब खराब नहीं होगा आपका दिमाग एकदम
मस्त काम
करेगा ठीक है मस्त काम करेगा ना ना ना
आपको सॉल्व करके लाना है यही तो बात है आप
अब मैं सारे अगर हिंट देता चल जाऊ तो फिर
क्या आपका क्या फायदा होगा कोई फायदा नहीं
होगा थोड़ा डिफरेंट है डंप इनटू आउट फाइल
यह थोड़ा डिफरेंट कांसेप्ट है इसलिए छोड़
दिया कि थोड़ा एक्सप्लोर करो समझो चीजों
को भाई अब हर चीज में मैं इसमें तो हिंट
कुछ है हिंट दे दूंगा तो पूरा ही सॉल्व कर
लोगे तुम कोई सा भी इसमें हिंट दे दूंगा
सॉल्व कर लोगे क्यों कुछ दूसरा है ही नहीं
भाई हिंट ही इसका सलूशन है तो कैसे हिंट
दे देंगे तो इसको सॉल्व कीजिएगा पूरा का
पूरा यह आपके लिए एक टास्क है एंड
एसक्यूएल मैप टूल इंस्टॉल कर लीजिएगा अगर
आपका कालेस नहीं है तो कालेस में बाय
डिफॉल्ट आपकी आती है क्योंकि हम नेक्स्ट
क्लास में ना ऑटोमेशन फायरल बायपास एंड
लाइव टारगेट पर हंट करने वाले जो हमारा
नेक्स्ट क्लास होगा 35 क्लास ठीक है अब
खुश हो जाना सब लाइव टारगेट प हंट करेंगे
एसक्यूएल मैप ऑटोमेशन फायरल बायपास एंड
अलग-अलग कुछ कांसेप्ट जैसे कि डाटा लेंथ
हो गया आपका जैसे कि
आपका डेटा टैंपरिंग हो गई आपकी
फ्रेगमेंटेशन हो गई देयर आर मल्टीपल
थिंग्स एमटी वगैरह मतलब और भी कुछ
कांसेप्ट है जिसको हम समझेंगे ठीक है तो
नेक्स्ट क्लास में आ जाइएगा जरूर से जरूर
याद कीजिएगा और मैं आपको यह मत समझिए कि
मैं आपको पूरा क्यों नहीं बता रहा हूं यह
सारा क्यों नहीं सॉल्व कर रहा हूं यह आपके
लिए है यह सॉल्व ऐसे नहीं कर रहा कि मैं
सॉल्व नहीं करना चाहता हूं एंड आपको ऐसे
छोड़ देना चाहता हूं ये इसलिए नहीं किया
क्योंकि आपको मैंने हिंट दिया है हर एक
चीज स्पन फिडिंग मैं नहीं करूंगा आपको
हिंट दिया है और आपको ये सॉल्व करना है
जहां फसो ग वहां एक्सप्लोर करना है नोट्स
बनाने हैं लिखना है प्रैक्टिस करना है
बार-बार करना है किसी से पूछना नहीं है
हिंट नहीं लेना है पहले खुद पूरा ट्राई कर
लो ना पता चले तो डि फ्रक्स बग हंटर का जो
ग्रुप है उसमें आ जाना डिस्क्रिप्शन में
उसका लिंक मिल जाएगा किसी भी वीडियो के
डिस्क्रिप्शन में आपको लिंक मिल जाएगा
जाइए और वहां से ज्वाइन कर लेना ग्रुप को
ग्रुप नंबर टू है फर्स्ट फुल चु है वहां
नहीं आ सकते ठीक है समझ में आ
गया एवरीवन गॉट चलिए
दैट्ची सो मच गाइस बस आज के सेशन के लिए
हम इतना ही रखेंगे मैं अपना यहां पे ये
स्टॉप कर देता हूं हमारे जम को आई होप यू
गॉट समथिंग यू लर्न समथिंग एल इंजेक्शन का
कांसेप्ट आपका क्लियर हुआ होगा मेरे ख्याल
से मेरे हिसाब से एंड मजा आया मुझे भी
हालांकि काफी कम लोग हैं क्यों कम लोग हैं
क्योंकि मुझे पता है ये टॉपिक अ
इंटरेस्टिंग आपको तभी लगेगा या उन लोगों
को तभी लगेगा जब कोई हम लाइव हंट कर रहे
हैं डायरेक्ट डेटाबेस कुछ एग्जीक्यूट कर
दे रहे हैं कुछ निकाल दे रहे हैं कुछ ये
सब कर ले तभी उनको मजा आएगा कांसेप्ट
समझने में कोई मजा नहीं आएगा एंड इसी वजह
से क्या है कि बहुत सारे लोग साइबर
सिक्योरिटी में पीछे हैं कांसेप्ट नहीं
समझना उनको उनको बस फैंसी चीजें चाहिए कि
भाई अटैक हो गया रिजल्ट आ गया ये हो गया
वो हो गया एग्जीक्यूट हो गया ऐसी चीजें
निकल गई डाटा निकल गई ये फैंसी चीजें
चाहिए एक्चुअल चीजें उनको नहीं सखना है
जिनको एक्चुअल सीख सीखना है वो यहां पे
लोग अवेलेबल है एंड मुझे भी मैं सच बता
रहा हूं मुझे उन 38 लोगों से मतलब है जो
यहां अभी अवेलेबल है राइट नाउ टू लर्न द
कांसेप्ट मुझे उन बाकी कितने हजारों लोगों
से कोई मतलब नहीं है जो हमारे 3000 4000
5000 लोग जुड़े हैं ना हमारे साथ उनसे कोई
मतलब नहीं है लिटरली कोई मतलब नहीं है जो
यहां पर नहीं है क्योंकि स्टार्टिंग में
तो 50 से ऊपर थे बट अभी सब गायब हो गए
क्यों क्योंकि उनको मतलब
नहीं ठीक है तो जो यहां प्रेजेंट है मुझे
उनसे मतलब है बाकी किसी से मतलब नहीं है
इन द सेंस कि जो सीखना चाहता है जो बस
हवाबाजी करना चाहता है ऊपर ऊपर जाना चाहता
है वोह फिर उसके लिए बहुत दिक्कत आएगी आगे
चलके फिर उसको समझ में आएगा कि मैं क्या
बोल रहा था क्योंकि आपसे ज्यादा
एक्सपीरियंस लेकर मैं बैठा हूं इसी फील्ड
में पिछले सा साल से ज्यादा मैं बिता दिए
तो वह चीज मेरे को पता है कि भाई आपको
कहां पर क्या जानना चाहिए किस तरीके से
आपको वह कांसेप्ट समझने जो चीज है
कांसेप्ट वाली व कितनी हेल्प करेगी ठीक
है नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट क्लास 4 तारीख को चलिए
ठीक है गाइस देन थैंक यू सो सो मच फॉर
जॉइनिंग आई होप कि आप सब लोग हमारी जो
वीडियोस हैं क्लासेस उसको शेयर करते हैं
अपने कम्युनिटी में अपने दोस्तों के बीच
अपने बग
बाउंटीज जो लोग हैं उनके बीच और साइबर
सिक्योरिटी कम्युनिटी में अलग-अलग सोशल
मीडिया हैंडल्स के थ्रू क्योंकि उसी से
हमें सपोर्ट मिलता है एंड इनकरेजमेंट
मिलती है अभी देखो आप लोग ज्यादा इं
ज्यादा अटैचमेंट ज्यादा इंटरेक्शन दिखाते
हो तो आपकी क्लासेस भी आती है एंड इतना
कुछ प्रोवाइड कर रहा हूं मैं अभी तो बहुत
कुछ आना बचा हुआ है भाई अभी तो ऐसी ऐसी
चीजें आएंगी जो तुम सोच भी नहीं सकते थे
कि ऐसी चीजें भी आती है क्या फ्री क्लासेस
इस में ठीक है तो सबको धन्यवाद एंड गुड
नाइट टेक केयर